things are getting pretty spicy over in
eastern europe we now have reports that
russia has threatened military and
political consequences serious military
and political consequences if finland
and sweden try joining nato finland and
sweden are already having discussions
with nato they're actually involved in
the nato meetings over the defense of or
i should say the response to the russian
invasion in ukraine and while there are
some people who are saying well that's
not explicitly threatening war or
military action
if you actually look at what's been
going on for the past several weeks it
is there's been uh on unidentified
drones flying over nuclear plants in
sweden there has been russian activity
from kaliningrad into the baltic sea so
very much so sweden has been on high
alert for some time this statement is
basically saying there is going to be
some kind of action against you if you
go out against us and not only that
we already heard
vladimir putin say anyone who interferes
in their operation in ukraine will face
consequences never before seen in
history so i think it's fair to say
obviously everyone's going to try and
play some game of how they're describing
things to win pr points but this is
it's a veiled threat at the very least
but i think it's it's in my opinion it's
outright overt to say military
consequences so things are absolutely
starting to heat up we'll talk about
that we've got nato apparently it's the
for the first time they're having this
defensive meeting and then i want to
talk to you about propaganda because you
know what man
i go on reddit i go on reddit all the
time you guys know it
and it is the lowest of low tier
like propaganda i've ever seen produced
in favor of ukraine and i like ukraine
and i oppose russia's actions i think
it's all wrong and i'm just like your
propaganda
is garbage but it's it's just so
annoying to see bad propaganda i'm like
guys do better than this the ghost of
kiev thing that was cool the ace fighter
pilot took out six russian fighter jets
cool story the snake island one go f
yourself i like it but these memes are
just cringe
so we'll talk about that at the same
time rt has been taken offline and i
find i think that's absolutely wrong if
people want to see the russian
perspective on the war or see what
russia is claiming they should be
allowed to do it but apparently
anonymous has shut them down yeah i
don't know if i believe that but we'll
get into that stuff joining us to talk
about all of this is nick freitas you
want to introduce yourself oh well thank
you very much for having me on tim yeah
my name's nick
um
did some time in the military i'm
currently serving the virginia house of
delegates but yeah it's kind of an
interesting topic because my whole my
whole role in the military was
unconventional warfare and
counterinsurgency and so watching this
kind of unfold is is amazing um but
yeah i've been serving the last seven
years in virginia house delegates
representing the 30th district so thanks
for having me i mean it's it's it's
perfectly pertinent i suppose with your
military experience but also you had a
viral video recently condemning you know
like critical race theory in schools and
things like that and so i i think you
know before we even went live you were
giving it all away talking about school
choice and what's going on in these
schools and i'm like well you know it's
fine you'll just say it twice yeah
so that should be fun yeah yeah we got
ian what's up everybody i uh i've been
very inspired by your all the 20s i've
been rolling lately that you've been
reminding me about so i got a couple of
hundred-sided dice yeah about time to
start rolling hundreds yeah and one of
these is for tim i'm gonna let tim
decide
which one which one you'd like here you
go tim a 100-sided
dice one's rainbow-colored and one's
blue that's so cool very heavy it is a
giant metal ball hard metal all right
i'm going to roll it
oh my gosh that's loud yeah it's just
they don't play well in teams because
they take forever to roll all the way to
nick got the wide shot in front of nick
now
what do we get 22 23 23
it's a prime number nice
better than 20. good night ahead of us
all right what's up everybody
yeah and i'm also here i oh warmed nick
up by talking about anything and
everything i try not to talk about the
podcast topics but sometimes we get into
it it's gonna be great i'm really
looking forward to it before we get
started my friends we have an awesome
sponsor we have biotrusts ageless
multi-collagen you know i'm your love
and go to strongerbonesandlife.com
and you can secure your supply of
ageless multi-collagen for 51 up to 51
today you need this stuff it's excellent
it's for your joint your hair your skin
your nails today i was trying to do
what's called i don't know what it's
called in rollerblading it was a side
tuck i was launching off a ramp and
doing a sideways flip like a front flip
but sideways into this big air bag and i
got achy bones and knees so i definitely
need this stuff and i'm grateful for
biotrust sponsoring the show again
stronger bones in life they say you will
get a 60-day money-back guarantee
you will get the healthy aging support
of collagen in its ideal forms for every
order today biotrust will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date they have
provided over 5 million meals please
help biotrust hit their goal of 6
million meals this year
there it is non-gmo and free of
artificial colors flavors preservatives
and sweeteners it's free of gluten
antibiotics and rbgh and rbs tea nearly
no odor or taste for real i put it in my
weird drinks you often see i have this i
have this weird black lemonade today and
you can't even taste it it's it's fast
it's fantastic and so i definitely need
it with my old icky joints no clumping
unlike other supplements and you get
free shipping with every order free vip
life live health and fitness coaching
from biotrust team of expert nutrition
health coaches for life with every order
and their free e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin and i just want to say
in these times these trouble times the
culture war times special shout out to
everybody who's willing you know all of
our direct sponsors these are the kind
of companies you got to support because
they're willing to be involved with the
work that we do especially with all
these activists going crazy so again
stronger bones and life.com but don't
forget you can directly support us over
at timcast.com by clicking sign up
becoming a member and as a member you
keep our journalists employed we're
we've we've got on-the-ground reporters
we've got a team of journalists writing
new uh writing stories every single day
and we are all grateful that you guys
are supporting work plus you'll get
access to our exclusive members only
segments that we put up monday through
uh thursday around 11 or so p.m so
definitely go to timcast.com but don't
forget to smash the like button
subscribe to this channel right now
share the show any way you can let's
read that first story from the hill
russia threatens military and political
consequences if finland or sweden tries
joining nato
russian's foreign minister ministry
spokesperson maria zakharova warned
against other countries attempting to
join nato after russia started a war
with ukraine thursday finland and sweden
should not base their security on
damaging the security of other countries
and their
ascension accession to nato can have
detrimental consequences and face some
military and political consequences
zacharova said in a viral clip of a
press conference the ministry later
posted the same threat on its twitter
finland and sweden have given
significant military and humanitarian
support to ukraine since russia invaded
one pretext russia has given for
attacking ukraine is that nato would not
give any assurances that ukraine would
not be allowed to join the inter
intergovernmental military alliance see
i i'm gonna i'm gonna pause real quick
and say a few things
it's hard to believe any of the stuff
that's coming out you know i mean this
stuff is on twitter these videos and
these statements but a lot of the videos
a lot of the claims a lot of the
propaganda just seems that it seems like
attempts to manipulate the public it's
hard to know what's true
but
we have had stories coming out for quite
some time this is from france 24 the
russians are coming sweden on edge as
russia flexes military muscle it could
be
a long-standing propaganda campaign
i just don't really think so i think
russia has literally invaded russia has
said that they're engaged in a military
operation call it whatever you want
i think the reality is vladimir putin
feels like he lost he lost the influence
battle the u.s basically bought ukraine
he couldn't do it so here we are getting
into war the question is this threat
towards sweden and finland is it
legitimate or is putin just spiraling
out of control nick i'm wondering what
your thoughts are i don't you know i
don't see putin's never struck me as the
sort of guy that like just spirals out
of control
right the sort of guy that gets pissed
off and just starts you know
executing generals and and things like
that he's always seemed to be again i
don't think he's a good guy i think he's
a bad dude but i've also thought he was
a fairly calculating guy i mean the guy
has managed to stay in power this long
within russia uh within an environment
where it's it's fairly unstable from a
political perspective with a bunch of
oligarchs running around
um so i don't know i i don't i don't
i'm not convinced that he's at a point
where he's just kind of lost his mind
i think he's he's pushing to see how far
he can get away with what he's doing
um i i think he knows he's got a a
fairly short time to be able to act in
order to consolidate gains and then it's
all a question of what are you bringing
right when it shows up when inevitably
we get to the negotiating table what
does that look like and what are you
transferring in order to get what you
want so i don't i don't really
understand why he brings sweden and
finland into this um but
again
it's
what do you see what is being an
unstable guy what are your thoughts on i
mean you were talking about uh
unconventional warfare is that that's
where you specialized in when you're in
the military yeah so what are your
thoughts on everything we're seeing
right just to preface this
none of us uh here at least thought
putin would go this far with ukraine
yeah and so this seems very much like
conventional warfare but yeah and it
seems like they're saying uh while kiev
has some major gains they've taken down
a lot of russians russia's assets
they're going to lose and then there's
questions about what they can do in the
insurgency phase in the resistance phase
i don't look
everyone likes to talk about the fact
that russia is not the power of the
soviet union was that's absolutely true
right it's got a gdp that's a little bit
bigger than mexico's right it's got a
population of about you know 150 million
um so not what the soviet union was
but when we talk about russia doesn't
have the gdp to fight a sustained war
yeah you know who also doesn't ukraine
so this this isn't about them having to
fight a war for years this is about how
quickly can they get their gains
consolidate those gains and then put
themselves in a good position on the
negotiating table and so from ukraine's
perspective they had to know that you're
not going to go toe-to-toe especially
with the geography of ukraine it's not
like you can go fighting in the
mountains for 10 years like they did in
afghanistan right right it is built for
take warfare and the russians know a
little something about tank warfare um
especially in ukraine right there's a
lot of historical battles there but what
a lot of people don't understand about
this is
immediately following world war ii the
ukrainians fought like a 10-year
insurgency against the soviets
so there is a history of them fighting
over that area the borders of ukraine
are a little bit weird from an ethnical
state from an ethnic standpoint so at
this point this is a question of using
the natural geography that you have
right around the
in order to slow like the major advance
and then it's largely going to be urban
battles if you can be in an urban
environment and you can make them pay
because that's where asymmetric warfare
works really well for the defender for
the person that doesn't have the the
technology but if you're sitting in a
city right now and you've got an at4 an
rpg or or if you've got really something
good like the us gave them like javelins
okay you got a you know you got a 10 000
or a 15 000 rocket that's taking out a
you know 15 20 million dollar tank right
that that adds up
and so if they fight the insurgency
point in the urban areas which are kind
of behind the lines of the russian
advance and then they use their military
in order to kind of stop them at some of
these main geographical areas rivers
being one of the best they can drag this
out and they can make russia pay a much
higher price for it and that's what i
don't think russia can afford i want to
pull up this uh this google map real
quick of the you know eastern european
region you have moscow you've got russia
you've got ukraine here you can see it
when vladimir putin says he wants
assurances that ukraine won't be joining
nato i think tulsi gabbard came out and
she was like just give give them
assurances ukraine won't join nato it's
like have y'all looked i'm a fan of
tulsi but have you looked at a map right
yeah
estonia and latvia are eu are i'm sorry
our nato members oh yeah they're already
on the border they take it very
seriously and then if you go up and you
look at sweden which you know look
russia's got saint petersburg they've
got kaliningrad in the baltic sea sweden
not nato but now obviously russia's
threatening finland not nato but also
putin
putin well russia is basically
threatening them they're both in these
same meetings with nato
so when moscow was like oh we don't want
nato on our borders like they've been
there dude no no no i mean i i i know
sweat uh sweden and finland but to act
like this is the the line for him now i
i perhaps it's fair to say he i i'm not
saying he's spying out of control like a
madman
but he's desperate yeah you know russia
is not the power it once was and it's
being weakened it's being pressed upon
it's already got nato on its borders and
now it's gonna have sweden finland
ukraine putin he's done his only option
basically is to bend the knee to the
west and say you know how may i serve my
leash and he will he doesn't want to do
that no so he's like i'll go out with a
bang i suppose i think he i think he is
a um i think he's someone that wants to
believe in the greatness of russia that
would love to see the russian empire
once again on a on a global stage as
something that's respected as opposed to
kind of a second rate power um
again you're growing up he was once a
kgb right officer like this was a guy
that believed in the greatness of russia
regardless of whether or not he was a
communist right and i think he sees
again these countries that used to be in
the russian sphere of influence
um he's finding different excuses for
costas belly in order to justify why
he's going to war
i think some of this too has to do with
internal dynamics within russia i mean
you have a decreasing birth rate you
have you know records showing that
you've got a record number of of you
know kids in their teenage years that
are alcoholics
right
look i don't think any of us are shocked
by the fact
that there are plenty of times when
throughout history when a domestic
leader had problems at home a war abroad
was a great way to you know kick start
your your nation and get them focused on
something you know the the
again the greatness of whatever it was
and look our nation hasn't been beyond
that sort of enticement in the past
um but so yeah i don't buy that it was
ukraine potentially joining like would
this have happened anyway yeah i don't i
don't think nato was the fulcrum i think
nato made a convenient excuse for putin
to do something that he already wanted
to do they're trying really hard to push
this this propaganda it's anti-trump
propaganda that's it's it's so
man the propaganda is mind-numbing ugh
you know it's under trump putin did not
make these moves no and so the only real
response they have because the first
thing i started seeing from these
activists was
that um oh oh thank heavens trump wasn't
president when this happened because
we'd be worse off and i was like for
four years putin backed off yeah and
they said now they're saying it's
because trump gave them everything they
wanted because he was he was opposed to
nato it's like he got nato to pay them
more to pass more money yeah i mean if
anything he was he was stabilizing it in
a sense oh so
no no this is the part where and and i i
was i was the other night i was just
kind of pissed off and i said you know
we're i said i can't remember how long
were way for a bunch of european
countries to you know ask the united
states to intervene in the ukraine only
to turn around six months later from now
and [ __ ] about the united states
intervening in ukraine
right because they're they're always
willing to fight to the last drop of
american blood to sustain their welfare
states right
so this idea that when trump came in and
basically told nato hey look a treaty is
an agreement it's a legal agreement and
you're not living up to your part of it
that that lit a fire under their ass and
quite frankly they needed it and and the
other thing was is that putin also
understood
that trump didn't draw and look i didn't
there was there's things about trump's
policy i didn't necessarily agree with
but
trump didn't do this thing that like
obama did where it's we're going to draw
a fake line in the sand and then when
you cross it we're going to draw a
different line in the sand
putin expected that if trump said you do
this we're going to do this that he
would do it
and that's that's a big part of when
when foreign leaders
you know cannot calculate what you're
going to do
it actually and you have the ability to
actually make good on your your threats
that's a far different dynamic than joe
biden ripping everyone out of
afghanistan which again i wanted the
troops to come home from afghanistan but
ripping everyone out the way that he did
surrender oh my gosh it's it's
afghanistan seemed like they botched
that on purpose
how you abandoned bagram
it was just mind-numbingly insane i
cannot i'm sorry i know i love to cite
hanlon's razor never a tribute to malice
that which can be explained by
incompetence but in this instance i'm
like there's no way you thought
abandoning our air force base before
evacuating people made sense maybe
because biden's a bureaucrat with no
military i don't think it's any military
experience does he even have any
military knowledge well
he surrendered and routed our troops but
the guys but the guys advising him
certainly did now i
this is the part where this is the part
where i do think
we've seen this trend within within
politics and some of the rhetoric and
and the direction the left is going and
i'm not talking about everyone that
might be a democrat right or a liberal
i'm talking about the hardcore
progressive left
they honestly believe some of this crap
where it's like oh we're just going to
pull everybody out
by september 11th in 2021 and that's
going to be that's going to be our
market it's going to show that we're
dedicated to peace i honestly think
biden is someone that is making a
political calculation based off of photo
ops
and
honestly had no idea it was going to go
this badly even though again to your
point anybody should have been able to
look at that but like you cannot pull
out this way but putin is watching
things like that
let's talk about uh let's talk about
donald trump and vladimir putin we have
the story for the new york post trump
talks about putin mocking merkel and
more at mar-a-lago boy did they bury the
lead on this one the story is about
donald trump threatening to hit the
capitals of russia and china
this is i mean these are bold statements
so you want to know why why is it that
vladimir putin did not invade ukraine
under trump
there are these there's there's this top
post on reddit where they're like
because you know russia put bounties on
soldiers in afghanistan and trump didn't
even do anything about it story was fake
yeah and so this is what they believe no
no let me show you exactly what it is i
will scroll down and give you this
there are several other stories making
the rounds too this is from the from the
article and they are even more
provocative one has it that trump noting
that putin seized land from georgia when
george w bush was president and seized
the crimean peninsula when barack obama
was president warned putin against a
land grab on his watch if you move
against ukraine while i'm president i
will hit moscow
putin reportedly scoffed no way and
trump said all those beautiful golden
turrets will be blown up
he reportedly said the same thing to xi
jinping that if he made a move against
taiwan it would be met with an attack on
beijing she like putin is said to have
been stunned though it's possible
neither man believed trump was serious
i kind of don't like the idea of bombing
civilian targets immediately as soon as
a regional war happens
but let it be said trump was was called
a madman by his enemies and his
supporters
and
and i just want to say
i don't i don't believe trump would bomb
civilians i mean he's the guy who said
we're calling off the airstrike on iran
because
too many people would die
but
trump is notorious for the big ask
he he exaggerates his position and then
pulls back to a more reasonable spot
that's what he does he says i'll buy
that uh you know i'll you know if i'm
doing the job i want a million dollars
and they say oh a million that's crazy
okay how about half a million now he's
getting you to half a million dollars in
this instance he goes to moscow he go or
he goes to uh putin
if you invade ukraine
i will hit moscow and putin's like no
and trump's like yes
and putin's like
okay
this guy's this guy's a little off his
you know and they know that he'll be out
in four years they know that the
american democracy is our republicanism
so putin was like
let the you know hold like the
braveheart mean
hold and then biden comes in he's like
we good yeah
well and nobody nobody thinks i mean
again this is also some people
think that diplomacy works with
everybody because they honestly believe
that well if we all just sat around the
room and we talked and we understood one
another like
i can't remember it was that said that
you know israel and and gaza understand
each other oh they do yeah they they
don't they don't like sure so this idea
that if we just had a better
conversation i think we'd be fine no
when you're when you're dealing with
people that are
either dictatorial or
quasi-authoritarian or whatnot what they
respect is strength and that strength
has to be backed up with with the first
of all the capability to do it could you
actually make good on these promises
they all know we could and then it's the
idea of would he actually do this
and even if they don't think he would
the bottom line is that there's a part
of him like
damn he might he might actually do it
that is the sort of stuff that can stop
a war from ever taking place in the
first place and can check aggression you
have to have the capability and the
willingness and you have to be able to
negotiate in a way that your your your
enemies don't know what you're going to
do but know that the wildest crap is
still on the table you ever play po you
play poker at all a little bit not very
good sometimes so when you're only with
my life when you're playing hold them
against somebody who doesn't know how to
play poker there's a certain advantage
they have in that it's hard to know what
they're doing because they're ready all
over the place
so i i remember when i when i first like
i was like 20 i played a game a poker
i had two seven off suit
and i went all in on it
and i got a full house oh wow and i beat
a guy who had ace king you know it was
just it was it was a good hand and he
ended up losing thinking you can't have
anything but like i got ace king and i
think he ended up with like i don't know
i don't think he had anything but i
ended up winning and he got angry he was
like why did you i'm like oh i won
didn't i oh
i have lost more hands with pocket aces
than like that's right right because you
you're like it's a i mean it's a
fantastic it's one of the best hands to
go in on pre-flight pre-flight maybe ace
king suited but anyway the point is with
donald trump putin's like i don't think
he'll bomb moscow but i also don't know
if he knows what he's doing yeah i don't
know how he'll respond
how can how can you make a plan for war
what sun tzu said
win the war before you know before you
actually started
how could you plan against a man like
trump he was like look we're gonna wait
a few years because i don't know what
this guy's doing well and he was the the
other thing too that i think shocked a
lot of people and one of the things that
impressed me most about trump is that is
how reserved he actually was in foreign
policy when it came to actually
deploying people into harm's way to get
shot at right there's a lot of other
again joe biden there's the whole teddy
roosevelt thing right walk softly carry
a big stick
joe biden mumbles and carries no stick
and and once people get used to that
idea then they know they can walk all
over you and it doesn't matter what your
capability is because you don't have the
willingness to use it
that whereas trump had the capability
again he was actually a lot more
reserved when that whole thing happened
in iran and it was no we're not going to
do this because i'm not going to
one it's immoral to kill a bunch of
people had nothing to do with any of
this two it doesn't make sense on a
practical level to keep you know uh to
create a bunch of enemies off of killing
civilians
but when it came to syria
and then there was a legitimate thing to
strike like he struck he struck hard he
was in there quick he didn't have any
you know
aspirations to like remake syria it was
just this is the weirdest thing about
the whole the whole argument about trump
and you know what he what you know uh
why putin didn't attack
because they're acting like trump was
was favorable to russia
and i guess in some ways you can argue
trump's disdain for nato but trump's
disdain for nato there's a video going
around of trump sitting at a meeting
table with them saying
why are we
paying for your defense against russia
and then you're negotiating billion
dollar gas deals making you dependent on
russia thank you it was not helping
russia that trump sanctioned nordstrom
2.
joe biden may 2021 lifted the sanctions
on nordstrom 2 and all of us were like
why are you as he was shutting down the
keystone pipeline right right and then
and then
it was appeasement is that what it was
the idea was well if we give him a
little then we can take it away if he
does bad and it's like he's got nothing
to lose then yeah he's like you gave me
free stuff so i can invade anyway and
lose what i already didn't have whatever
yeah and then he did yeah putin did well
and he also again it's this idea i i've
it's incredible to me that
there's this honest belief that
anybody's capable of sitting down at the
table and no you have completely
different objectives you have completely
different worldviews you you have you
know completely different capabilities
interests etc now that's not to say that
you still can't have a productive
conversation someone engage in effective
diplomacy but effective diplomacy only
takes place when people actually believe
that there will be consequences for
their actions if they go against you
and i i think
you know i wonder about vladimir putin's
frame of mind but i do know we talk a
lot about uh strassau generational
theory you're familiar with it fourth
turning
hard times make strong men i think about
the motivations of vladimir putin he
wants he wants russian greatness he
wants that empire back and he knows you
know what maybe things will get worse
off for the people of russia but that
will be good for them
spiritually in the long run i'm not
saying it literally well i'm saying
that's just mentality and so his idea is
look we go to war we are more are are
more willing have have have less to lose
than these western nations and it will
harden up our people a little bit in the
long run maybe he thinks he's planting
something what i understand maybe i'm
playing devs advocate america took iraq
russia takes ukraine china takes taiwan
then we're done with it can we just be
done with it and move on i don't i don't
can we not can we trade iraq for yeah i
would love to trade around maybe no
conquest how about that yeah greenland
is going to be super valuable in the
21st century england and beyond how
about this sweet russia you can have
ukraine who's going to agree with that
denmark isn't it
the kingdom of denmark yeah talk about
getting get an ally early because in a
hundred years they're going to be mega
powerful unless someone sees this yeah
it's going to melt and it's going to be
so much oil and lithium we have we have
a property
yeah we do have alaska we conquered it
didn't we no we bought it we bought it
we conquered hawaii senators yeah we
conquered hawaii yeah yeah okay yeah
wasn't there like like 10 years ago i
think it was a bunch of native hawaiians
stormed like the state building and
occupied it or something yeah they still
get pissed about that yeah a lot of the
islanders well yeah they're like we had
a king like america came and took it
while america wanted a pacific you know
military operation it looks like uh
putin wants the black sea he wants to
control the black sea well okay so this
this is what i think is interesting i
was talking to a buddy of mine christian
who works with us really good historian
and um he's done a lot of research on
what's going on in ukraine and were
talking about okay what are some of the
possible angles here right because the
most obvious one is all right crimea
used to be
part of russia it actually got worked
into the border with ukraine after
uh nikita khrushchev shut down the uh
the
insurgency that the ukrainians had
launched against the soviet union right
it got crimea it went from the russian
ssr over to the ukrainian ssr it was
like it's not a big deal we're all the
ussr right well when you have the
breakaway republicans now all of a
sudden you have these areas which
ethnically culturally you could even
argue historically
are more russian that are now not part
of that so okay again if you're looking
for causes bella you could say maybe he
was he's interested in getting back
parts of russia that he thinks always
belong to russia and want to be russian
anyways
but as i look at the black sea and as i
look at the the
belt and road initiative by china and i
look at what they're trying to do with
respect to their overland trade
um
i have a feeling that the more access
you have the caspian sea the more access
you have to the black seed the more
important that that's going to be from a
trade and economic perspective not to
mention the fact that if he gets away
with doing this in ukraine who the hell
is going to stop him when it comes to
kazakhstan uzbekistan oh absolutely and
now we're talking about minerals we're
talking about you know overland routes
we're talking about natural gas who's
going to stop a man and look at look at
the strategy he's using donald trump
called it genius savvy and the media has
cnn actually read an article saying
trump sides with putin oh my god did you
did you trump said it was a genius move
it was savvy and it wouldn't have
happened under me it's sad
so i don't think that's siding with
putin i think he's like you know you
mentioned acknowledging that your enemy
is a genius is can be very good to
defeat your enemy that's right yeah and
so you mentioned you know in in ward the
negotiating table people will only
respect power respect often people uh
people conflate some words with
positivity like greatness excitement or
respect you can respect someone and
despise them oh yeah you can be excited
and and and in despair not happy yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you can be a great man and pure evil
genghis khan great is just
magnitude
but we often view greatness in a
positive way like he was a great man
it's like that could just mean a
powerful man a conqueror yeah right
right and there's an example and when
it's funny too you would think the same
left that whenever when trump said make
america great again and they all came
out with their little head we'll make
america good again yeah it's like okay
so you get that there's a difference
right between the two and then when when
he comes out and says yeah this was a
genius move on his part for these
reasons
it could be genius i'm bad what was he
referencing when he said it was genius
so vladimir putin says oh look these
regions are independent i'm going to
send in a peacekeeping force to keep the
peace and trump was actually being
sarcastic it was like oh yeah
peacekeeping force look at all those
tanks that's a peacekeeper of course
and they're like he's siding with putin
he was he was being he was being
sarcastic yeah but it was
it was a clever move for putin to be
like well you know they're independent
so we can go help him and it's like oh
yeah until you win a war without before
it begins basically let's but let's talk
about you know i we we always do it the
the double standards and the hypocrisy
of our good democrat voter and activist
friends take a look at this story from
timcast.com ukraine says they have
supplied 18 000 weapons to citizens
anti-gun leftists celebrate their
efforts my favorite is occupy democrats
let me let me pull up this image from
defiant elves
occupy democrats first tweeted no
civilian needs an ar-15 regardless of
what whatever mental gymnastics you do
you are a very special breed of stupid
and they then you know about six years
later breaking ukraine's interior
minister announces that 10 000 automatic
rifles have been handed out to the
civilians of kiev as they prepared to
fight tooth and nail to defend their
homes against putin's invasion rt if you
stand with the brave people of ukraine
now hold on hold on hold on everybody
i think occupy democrats are right i
think joe biden's correct you know what
i was wrong to criticize the
establishment when they said putin was a
very real threat i stand corrected you
guys you're right i think our government
should join in as well and give all of
the united states citizens some
automatic weapons yes so because
vladimir putin's such a big threat we
could be now
and china you know oh but
but putin so um i'll take a i'll take a
fully uh i'll select fire kalashnikov
yeah yeah
yeah something while you're handing them
out
regarding this guy's first tweet he's
talking to the the air and then he says
you're stupid this is something i think
people should avoid this is a little off
topic when you're when you're using
social media and you're like complaining
towards someone and you they start
insulting them if you do it on social
media a lot of people that are
unintendedly reading it are going to
feel like you're insulting them yeah so
don't do that you are a very special
breed of stupid who are you talking to
me no they're talking to themselves
apparently because now they're tweeting
that he's they and they actually say
civilians like no civilian is an air 15.
to be fair they're handing out collision
of costs oh yeah so that's okay so you
need to keep in mind here they think
they still think ar stands for automatic
rifle yes so what's what's crazy is they
don't think any civilian needs a
semi-automatic rifle but they are
thrilled about fully automatic aks
that's actually a really good point
maybe maybe we're being mean to our good
friends
no civilian needs an ar-15 what they're
really saying is it's semi-auto that's
not that's sufficient no you need to
select fire correct right right not
against tanks
and if one of those selects is not full
auto with an occupied democrats is not
satisfied that's right there you go
so so maybe what they're really saying
is that um no so no civilian needs this
uh uh a semi-auto single shot come on
yeah you need full auto that's right
only the best that's what they're
getting at the whole time all right
let's
let's talk about the asymmetrical
warfare though because um i mean this is
the reality
when when when you try to invade someone
else
that the big challenge for vladimir
putin is going to be
demoralized
russian soldiers a finite amount of them
versus the entirety of of ukraine
civilians who have remained who are
gonna be like i'm gonna fight you which
is actually surprising there's there's a
number i i think a lot of people and i
think putin thought
this would be something where hey as
soon as the armored divisions go rolling
across the border you know presidents
leaving the country you know uh nope
you put on body armor yeah i mean you
gotta you gotta hand it to him like
shenko took out a gun right i don't know
if i believe it it's propaganda but it's
good propaganda yeah if you're trying to
rally i mean let's face it if especially
when you're engaging in asymmetric
warfare you are the weaker party
propaganda is one of the key things
you're going to we still got democrats
that think that we lost the ted
offensive
right why because walter cronkite said
we lost the ted offensive oh i thought
we lost the ted offensive yeah didn't
people just get rolled over yeah north
vietnam and all all down vietnam didn't
the the americans get annihilated no no
didn't what happened yeah are you
serious on the ted defensive what
happened yeah oh oh okay well real quick
segway yeah yeah okay
so
so yeah in vietnam the viet cong
launched a massive attack all throughout
the country during tet which was
supposed to be a ceasefire within the
the vietnamese calendar right and so
they they they made like some
fairly
major gains quickly but with like in
several weeks
they had taken massive amounts of
calories we're like talking like 20 to
one at that point it was after the tet
offensive that the north vietnamese
actual north vietnamese army had to
start coming in and supporting because
we had almost wiped out the viet cong
after the ted defensive they they threw
the kitchen sink at it and they got
obliterated so it looked bad overnight
be partly because our own military you
know leaders were saying oh yes they're
on their heels they can't do anything
well they launched this major offensive
that was unexpected they got temporary
gains but they got destroyed but it
didn't matter the propaganda campaign
that went along with it made it look
like one the military or the the
government was lying to the people which
is certainly not hard to believe and
then the other two was that this never
would have happened if we were actually
in the good shape that we were and as
tom a soul likes to say when a democracy
decides you've lost the war you've lost
it
and so that was the problem but again if
you look at something like this the
propaganda component for an asymmetric
force is critical psychology is one of
the most important things in a war yeah
that's why we're seeing so much
propaganda because
making people feel like we can win we
should win and we have to win is
important to keeping people in the fight
so there's a video of poroshenko you
know throwing a a a strap over he's got
he's got a rifle of some sort and he's
like i'm here on the ground and he's
like here's all the you know other
people i'm fighting with you've got
president zielinski and he's like i'm
with the prime minister i'm with the
cabinet from this guy we're here on the
ground he's got like a vest on
because the people of ukraine they're
going to see that and they're being
handed out guns yeah and they're going
and when you see your leader on the
battlefield with you they're going to be
like it's um like my favorite movie the
patriot with mel gibson i often inside
good movie when he says hold the line
and he runs back when they're retreating
and then they they pull forward and win
that's the thing but let me tell you
what you know you mentioned we got into
vietnam i gotta i gotta tell you the
story i read it's fascinating
so uh the us was trying to engage in
psychological warfare and something i
read on the internet perhaps not true
and so what they did was they knew that
the vietnamese were very superstitious
so they made these these creepy
recordings of wailing haunting
vietnamese like vietcong soldiers saying
you know uh why did i fight i should
have gone home they believe they believe
uh that if you are not given a proper
burial you're forced to haunt wherever
it was you died so in in the the you
know the forestry the jungle or whatever
they're playing in these loud speakers
wailing vietcong voices saying
flee while you still can or you'll be
trapped like me
it was so effective the south vietnamese
fled as well and so they had to stop
doing it
i don't know if it's true it sounds
amazing it's magical it's one of those
stories you hear you know it's probably
apocryphal or something yeah it's what
it says
if it's not true it ought to be right
right right right i mean
it's kind of messed up though you know
going after people's like it's like
psychic attack on them superstitious
cultures tend to get wiped out i think
are there any that exist anymore i don't
think so there's a lot of superstitious
cultures like like the christians cal
berkeley no
there's christian and islam which are
both kind of superstitious there's tons
of
like americans have tons of
superstitions but like it's easy to
manipulate someone if they're supposed
to go go to a casino and you will see oh
i didn't have a superstition
or a sporting event yeah you'll see it
you'll see a guy like tapas can five
times well that concerns me because
superstitious people are easy to
manipulate well it's like it's like
michael scott says i'm not superstitious
but i am a little stitched
[Laughter]
yeah man so so uh let it be known
they're giving out all these guns to
regular people because it works yeah i
want to see biden hitting a speed bag i
need some motivation
get on the floor bro yeah let's go
ah that's a funny
speed i'll tell you what what'll be
interesting on this though is that and
this is the part where okay again how
does ukraine stall russia how does
ukraine like capture the the press and
the media and the propaganda and all of
this
and and this is going to be interesting
because the first war we've seen like
this where literally everybody has got
access to the world to some degree from
their phone yeah so you imagine uh
partisans out there doing this sort of
stuff and then making a tick tock about
it
right that that's going to be that's
going to be a fascinating thing to
potentially watch from not just from a
propaganda perspective but a sharing
information perspective because if you
don't think terrorist organizations
already use social media in order to
coordinate their activities
um
that there's
regardless of what ends up happening
here there's going to be a lot of
research and study going into how social
media influenced it from a propaganda
from a coordination standpoint uh
because there's there's good ways for
partisans to fight and there's really
stupid ways for partisans to fight and
partisans should not be taking on a t90
with their ak-47 right this is it's it's
just crazy i i i'm trying to figure out
why putin would do this
and the only thing i come up with is
it's it's the last great hoo-rah of a
dying empire if they're not part of nato
if i play crusader kings 2. you know i
play a lot of like battle conquest grand
simulation strategy games and if you
have a lot of countries with a defensive
pact against you but one of them isn't
in the pact that's the country you hit
and you take it fast and then you're
done and then no one complains anymore
it's just back to base zero again and
hopefully no one else signs up for the
pact and if someone drops out of the
pact they're hungry they're a meaty
target oh he's got a he's got a
war-weary united states which is the
only one that has any teeth he's got a
europe that's been you know hit by covet
and doesn't want to deal with this crap
and everyone everyone on the western
side can say
ukraine wasn't a part of nato now if you
do it to poland we'll be pissed porn's
not in nato excuse me if you do it to
estonia right we'll we'll be pulling
this panzernator yeah
yeah estonia latvia lithuania should we
get out of nato
yeah what do you think cause we've we've
had those conversations here yeah yeah
all the wait we do we do pull all the
weight it's going to be interesting to
see what happens because well nato
hasn't been attacked right so it'd be
interesting to see well not that i'm
wishing for this
um i do think that there's something to
be said and this is a part and this is
the part where i'm i'll probably get a
little bit amped up
um
because again i've lost friends overseas
fighting wars that
you know i'm not so sure where were the
best decision on america's part um
but one of the things that has has
maintained the level of peace that we've
seen since world war ii and obviously
there's been horrible complex conflicts
in vietnam in korea and other places
that we've been involved in that we
haven't been involved in but
nothing like the massive bloodshed we
saw in world war one and world war ii
and the reason why we have that and the
reason why for the last 30 years we
haven't even imagined a conflict like
this the reason why this is surprising
the living piss out of everybody
is because of us military dominance
that's why the same thing that a lot of
our allies are constantly bitching about
and and coming to the united states and
talking about oh you know they're always
throwing their weight around they're
always going yeah and and because we
have and because people know we can
it has kept people at bay and no one's
going to convince me otherwise it really
happens
yeah and so now we're at a point
where you do you have a war weary united
states you have a global pandemic that
took place we have a country that we
have no legal obligation to defend
and i think the the the kind of the
world order
post-cold war is being challenged right
now by putin
and he's probably picked the best
possible time to do it
and and again that's why i said that the
same countries that will want the united
states to intervene to do the heavy
lifting for them if we decide to do it
will be bitching about us six months
from now and so i don't think we should
now does that mean do we we pull out of
things like nato i think there's i think
there's value
with with the united states being the
preeminent military power
and i i think that does do something to
preventing other nations from getting a
little bit froggy when they shun it
but one of the things again that i
appreciated about how trump handled this
was he went back to nato and he made it
very real possibility that you might not
be able to rely on us because you're not
pulling your weight
and that's not the same for allies that
we have in like south korea or taiwan
they do pull their weight they do
recognize the threat they do recognize
their responsibility to hold back the
threat and yes they depend on the united
states for support but they don't they
don't have this expectation that they
don't got to do the fighting because we
got this
and so i think
one of the positive things that could
come out of this is a lot of these
countries that it's become real popular
to trash the united states
um are going to realize that you know
what what do you think your country
would look like western europe
if it was putin that had the military
and economic power that the united
states had you think we'd be having
these conversations nope you think we
were talking about eastern ukraine or
you think we'd be talking about the
south of france right now
so
just remember as much as the united
states may screw up on our foreign
policy as much as we might
at a time where we had all the power all
the money all the military might
show me the country
that we annexed into the united states
in order to expand our own empire or
iraq
but we didn't
we don't we don't own iraq not on paper
no no not not at all i mean again the
way that
you look at you look at russia if russia
takes over ukraine
watch what happens in ukraine it's going
to be nothing like what happened yeah i
was really impressed with the
spanish-american war what i've read
about it is that the americans basically
liberated cuba for better or worse they
didn't invade and take it they get they
kicked the spanish empire out and we're
like now cuba's free yeah i mean we
didn't do that in the philippines but
right we didn't do that in philippines
this is not me suggesting that the
united states military has not had our
own little brush with empire we've done
things that we shouldn't have done i
mean go look at what lincoln was saying
about the mexican-american war go look
at what grant was saying about the
mexican-american war about how we we
kind of picked a fight with the country
we knew he could kick the crap out of
and then got a lot of territory from it
so like again i'm not saying we're we're
perfect
but if you look at the the situation in
the world it has been the the level of
peace and security that has existed in
certain parts of the world especially in
western europe has been as a direct
result of u.s military it's the
kissinger limited war doctrine he was a
big part of creating this idea that
we're going to create we're going to
fight proxy wars only so that we don't
go to total war i i mean i'm not a huge
kissinger fan me neither but um but that
was his yeah i'm not a huge kissinger
fan and i'm i think it's i don't like to
call it the proxy war idea that like
okay if we just get involved in a bunch
of little wars we'll stop big ones i do
think there's an argument to say that
there is such a thing as the sudetenland
moment
right where there was a point where the
french military the the british military
if they had intervened
in sudan land or if they'd intervened
when you know the nazis were going into
czechoslovakia and just carving it up
because they could
would with that whole scene
turn out a lot differently than if they
waited all the way till poland and and i
i think there's an argument to be made
there i i think there's an argument to
be made that you you identify when
someone has larger aspirations when they
have the military and capability to do
it and you intervene at a point where
they realize that okay we're not going
to get away with this you don't let them
build up a certain significant amount of
power to where they now can potentially
get away with that's kind of what we've
been doing in iran well like i've heard
stuxnet we blew up infrastructure i
think have they targeted them with
weapons blow up weapons depots and stuff
i don't know how hot it's gotten the
stuff the stuxnet was obviously you know
fairly significant and they've also
tried to manage their growth through
through um sanctions and so we could
have done that to germany looking back
in retrospect we could have tried to
to somehow disrupt their rise to power
but it was internal it was like how
could we get involved and stop the
military machine from creating itself no
i think it's more of and again i'm i'm
i am very
i tend to i always side with
non-interventionists and then you need
to explain why something is so
significant the united states men and
women need to bleed for it right that's
my starting point now when you're
talking about something like germany
again when you have internal issues i i
tend to say look you stay out of those
those are internal issues piece of west
ophilia right
but
once you start seeing
naked aggression like you did with the
sudan land with germany or like you did
with czechoslovakia
then i i think there is some argument to
say like okay is it is it appropriate at
this point to intervene on some level
now now what there's a big difference
there's there's a you know there's uh
i'm trying to think of the word now um
there's levels of force that you apply
right there's an escalation of force
not everything has to be like you went
into sedate land i'm nuking berlin right
it's not that but it sounds like trump
yeah right
but that's the thing it's there's a
difference between okay what's going to
be your escalation of force right that's
what you know that's not what you share
with the rest of the world
you want you want putin thinking you you
send one russian troop into ukraine
right and i'm i'm going into moscow
right it's going to be i've been setting
up a trump hotel in downtown
right because he doesn't know if you're
actually going to do it and so that's
where there's a difference between okay
what should be our actual strategy
versus what sort of strategy should we
project
right and our enemies don't get to know
this one they just get to know what
we're capable of biden said recently you
know the the minor encouragement it
depends on if it's a minor incursion he
gave that was a piece that was pro-empty
preemptive appeasement
should have said outright we'll go into
moscow binds the neville church we're
not going to be playing
or i mean and worse possibly the
buchanan yeah but he could have said we
won't tolerate this europe won't
tolerate this ukraine poland the baltic
states western europe none of it if
putin makes this move we go into moscow
day one
try me
yeah you get the president of france
germany and the united states the thing
is here's what i'll say though if biden
had said that
he would have flopped show a hands on
who believed him
i don't know
he would have been reading a prompter
and he would go come on man we're go
we're going to moscow we're going to
whatever
look here forget it corn pop
exactly i don't
vladimir putin's a bad dude who's got
some bad boys
someone called putin a bad dude
yesterday or was that you might have
called him a bad dude earlier
i think he was going to say bad mother
in the video you can hear him start to
say the word mother and he stops himself
and says dude instead yeah and said that
dude biden yeah when he listens because
this is a dude real weird bad dude
this is like when when hitler went into
poland to like reconquer part of poland
that had been stripped away after the
first world war and give it back because
apparently he said there was a genocide
of german expats in poland that they
were committing
putin says the same thing there's a
genocide of russians in eastern ukraine
that's been going on for eight years
i've heard an inkling of this in the
media i don't know if it's real or
complete propaganda but this was
hitler's reason for invading poland or
part of it probably also to connect you
know more land bridges and stuff because
he had hitler was like ready to take
over the war there's there's a conflict
in in the donbass region and you've got
people saying yeah the separatists are
dying you get people saying ukrainians
are dying and both sides will use what
they can to justify their positions yeah
i don't know who's more right or more
morally right i don't know i i know that
both sides are making those assertions i
i think that i think putin is doing what
he wanted to do
and then he found reasons to do it so
should we i guess my question in
is should we treat this like how we
treated hitler invading poland
where it's a different time and i'll
preempt that i don't i don't either
because america took iraq 20 years ago
and that that was gave the russians uh
no no opportunity to match the playing
field
you can't look two wrongs don't make a
right the u.s screwed up with iraq and
afghanistan they're screwing up today by
still being absolutely it's not like it
happened it's happening right now i'm
screwed up miserably leaving afghanistan
yeah but we can't be like well russia
gets to take a sovereign country because
the united states did it too that's
that's what and and even then the thing
that i go back to is that with iraq and
afghanistan there was there was no point
where iraq became the 51st state or or
afghanistan became a territory now again
i i don't i think there was huge
problems with the way we did a lot of it
now i don't think it was wrong to go
after the taliban i don't think it was
wrong to go after terrorism i don't
think any of that was wrong i think
there was something significantly wrong
with this idea that we're going to come
in here completely devastate whatever
current government is in charge and then
we're going to go ahead and recreate you
on our image but i think it was ron paul
who said that when it came to the
taliban after 9 11 we should have issued
letters of mark in reprisal specifically
targeting the group not the country not
going after talib they would have
cannibalized each other it would have
been awesome and instead it was like
let's nation build for 20 years oh no if
you if you look at the initial invasion
so again
in the military i was army special
forces it's better known as green berets
green berets focus on unconventional
warfare counter insurgency what does
that mean it means when we go into a
country we work by through and with
local allies the indigenous population
you look at the opening days of
afghanistan we're talking about you had
agency in there you had you know
several hundred green berets working
with the northern alliance and within
what a couple of months like they had
kicked the taliban out of like kandahar
and it was all buy through and with the
local population
and what would have been fascinating to
watch
and and and who knows what would happen
when it fascinated watches what sort of
organic solutions people would have come
up to and i'm sure it would have been
you know ugly and i'm sure it would have
been brutal at times everything else but
it wouldn't have been the united states
saying no no we're not just going to
fight the taliban we're going to take
over the entire country we're going to
take over the entire war it's now our
war we're going to help you with your
infrastructure we're going to help
because some of this i don't know if
you've ever seen read the book or seen
the movie charlie wilson's war a big
argument that they made is that we went
in there to help the mujahideen against
the soviets and then we didn't stand by
stay behind in order to help with some
of the infrastructure and so it got out
of hand and so this time as well we're
not going to repeat that mistake we'll
just double down and take over the whole
damn thing okay no you're trying to
impose certain cultural political social
changes on a culture that is not
necessarily interested in the social
changes that you're trying to affect it
doesn't matter whether or not you think
it's more moral than what they currently
have if you don't have buy-in there then
don't expect to be able to do it unless
you're willing to stay there for 100
years that's my concern with iraq they
say it's not a state but what's the plan
either we're going to be there for 100
years and it may be a state we have no
significant military right yeah it's
it's drawn down actually i i just don't
believe that i don't know where that
comes that idea comes from but it's like
locked down by the united states or
whoever is there
is it american weapons in the iraqi
puppets hands like it's a large nation
that has
well been well defended by the united
states for two decades oh we've been we
have not been a significant military
force on the ground in iraq for
gosh dang we're probably i mean
trying to think of the actual i was last
over there in 08 i think by 2013 we were
really drawing down significantly
um
so no i mean we have not had a
significant military presence in iraq
for i mean it's getting close to you
know yeah i think under obama he he
pulled all troops out of iraq put him
into afghanistan
he moved a lot down there then he
reinforced in afghanistan and by the
trump by the time trump was in there i
mean we have a huge embassy over there
there was some military presence but
that was one of the big complaints right
is that the reason why isil was able to
come in and do so much was because we
didn't have a significant u.s military
presence it seems like iraq is a staging
ground and so is afghanistan for like
russian interference iranian yeah
iranian they've got syria on the border
they're close to egypt in the south
they've got their eyes poking into saudi
arabia's north border well that's been i
mean saudi arabia was when the during
the cold war iraq uh especially syria
and all that that was very clearly a
soviet sphere of influence iraq was a
little bit because they were they were
taking most of the military equipment
egypt was soviet influence at a certain
point and then saudi arabia was more u.s
influence
um so it's just been an interesting
dynamic but keep in mind all those
borders were you know drawn by british
map makers
yeah after world war i want to
talk
i want to talk about modern day pirates
interesting conversation so uh we have a
story from cyber news anonymous leaks
database of the russian ministry of
defense
we had this report out of nbc that biden
had been presented with u.s plans for
cyber attacks direct attacks on russian
infrastructure
my position has been this for some time
the modern day pirate or corsair is
going to be the hacker
governments because we watch this happen
when uh back in the uh what did they
call it they called it the um
what was the time of the colonial uh
there was a there's a word for it like
oh scary pirates in the it's like it's
called like the sail era or something
like that oh yeah i know what you're
talking about yeah i say like colonial
times but um age of sale the age of sale
i think it was so uh the crowns would
issue letters of mark which basically
would commission a private warship to
attack enemies during time of war and
they could then capture it bring it in
and get a reward for it it was it was a
simple way of being like we don't got to
pay for your repairs we don't got to pay
for the ship you find your own crew you
bring a ship we'll pay you for it we'll
make it worth your while so governments
would effectively commission pirates
corsairs to go and you know stage these
these acts then the the other the the
other country would be like your your
ships are taking us oh no no those are
pirates don't look at us
so now we have anonymous hacking rt and
shutting them down hacking russian
ministry of defense and i don't buy it
first of all it's probably just like u.s
cyber warriors and if it isn't it's
effectively letters of mark the us
government saying private hackers go for
it and have fun take what you can from
russia think about it this way you've
got black hat hackers these are the
people who just want to rip you off and
steal what they can you got gray hat
hackers hacktivists politically
motivated and white hat corporate
security types
the government can go to these black
hats effectively pirates heck some of
them are probably pirating software
online literally and they'll be like
anything you steal from russia you will
not be prosecuted for
any information you rip off any
databases i'm willing to bet these
people are being given carte blanche by
the u.s you think they're getting paid
in the through the dark web or something
not necessarily paid but you i'm willing
to bet you've got like fbi going to this
blackout hacker and being like you know
we got that case against you we're going
to drop it if you can hit these russian
targets okay i think that's jack ruby
with the kennedy thing he was like a
mobster and they gave him he got off i
don't know about all that killing
killing a suspect i think it's as simple
as
you know we know who you are we know
you're good why don't you use your
skills to help the united states and
we'll look the other way so they're
blackmailing criminal hackers in part in
addition to maybe other things well
blackmail they're like we're going to
let you have carte blanche to steal
whatever you want we want no
repercussions we'll punish you unless
you steal whatever you want and then
we'll turn it off that's true i think
you're and again you're there there's
not a lot of people talking about this
because when when people talk about
we've just gotten so used to well the
president wants to go to war i guess
we'll go do that now um but there are
constitutional ways to deal with certain
threats you know one is the declaration
of war which is supposed to be done by
you know congress um
that's a fairly laborious process the
other thing that the president has as a
as a tool now again if you're if you're
going to engage in major action you're
still supposed to get approval from
congress to do this it's not like they
can do it but the whole idea of letters
and marketing reprisal and and kind of
the the last president i think we had
that issued one was madison
wow um and and it was and again don't
quote me on that but i think and again
part of that was going after the you
know the barbary pirate wars and the
united states didn't have a you know a
huge navy or anything like that and so
it made sense to do this
and i actually think it makes a lot of
sense toward non-state actors when
you're talking about terrorist
organizations and
like you said that the modern day
pirates are the
hackers man they can they they can do
more damage with a couple lines of code
um than you know
dude that's talking about deep fakes i
saw a video of a jet coming in and then
it fired two rockets at that building
that where the camera guy was and then
you hear the kids screaming and it's
like was that fake was that deep fake i
can't tell i saw a defect today that
really freaked me out it confused me and
i don't even want to believe it's it's
vladimir putin fishing but he has large
female breasts it's got to be fake it's
on the front page of reddit yeah that's
real that's that's right american
propaganda
that's been confirmed that that is a
that is an image on the front page of
reddit putin with large breasts fishing
and topless and i'm just like i see that
stuff and i'm annoyed by it because it
is it is it is top tier the bear bro
no pokem but make make the propaganda
good right like watching fighters like
there's there's video of like a plane
falling from the sky and they're like
the ghost of kiev and i'm like wow and
then uh it was uh grums he's like on
twitter he's like this the the ghost of
kiev is like an anime protagonist i'm
like well now you got some good problems
yeah
you know but like comic book character
but here's my question do you think and
this is this is interesting the hero's
journey masculinity right when you look
when you look at uh when you look at
social media there are certain platforms
that the better it is the worse it does
right and there's other platforms where
the the if it's bad it does better
because it seems more authentic people
think it's actually real people think
somebody you know
yeah but like when we're talking about
anything cringy i guess there's there's
this there's a meme on the front page of
reddit and it's megamind
and he's got it says like the size of it
says like the size of the hero's balls
yeah and then it says ball size and it
says mega and i'm like that's the
stupidest thing like what is this a
cultural reference to
like come on man do better as as one of
them but but but who's making memes with
mega mind i mean what is this that
someone
out of the book right that's a boomer
it's a boomer trying to make a meme
because propaganda some like 50 year old
intelligence guy he's probably listening
to the show and he feels all bad now
i worked really hard worked on it my
grandkids loved it don't worry mega
balls will come back one day
i'm just ahead of your time yeah but but
uh so this is not the first time we've
heard stories like hacking there's that
chinese hacking group yeah there was the
syrian electronic army and it turns out
um
i believe it's true because we did this
reporting advice that the person who was
actually running the syrian electronic
army was in moscow
so this is somebody who uh hacked
twitter
and then tweeted that obama had been
injured in some kind of attack on the
white house and the stock market in the
us dropped substantially before because
like the ap got hacked and tweeted it
out and then all of a sudden the market
dropped substantially and then bounced
back up but it only returned like 90
percent the rt's back up oh it is it is
yeah we're just talking about rt rt was
down for a long time today
and uh i just got it in it took a while
to load up but then i was able to load
it they finally figured out i get i
can't i can't load it interesting yeah i
just thought that they've been hacked
maybe i'm looking at a cache
a cached version you might be so i'd
like to go to um
actually.rt.com which is spanish
language rt that still works
yeah and then you just uh uh you just
translate it it works in english but i'm
getting this
message that says checking your browser
while loading rt you think that they're
they're logging everyone that's going to
rt now no i don't know but what i will
say is when i heard that anonymous shut
down rt and i'm like that does sound
like a lot of what anonymous is and i
also stress this point there is no
hacktivist collective called anonymous
that's just a it's pr it's a propaganda
it's manipulation it's always been
if you ask someone who's a hacker what
does it mean when anonymous hacks
something
they'll just look at you be like it
literally means anonymous exactly like
like someone signed it anonymous yeah
like if you wrote someone a letter i
hate you signed anonymous that's
literally what it means there's no
secret group like conspiring to hate you
well that's a random person that's what
the secret group wants you to think yes
yeah seriously that's very well but they
they are they they are typically like uh
you know they take down websites they
they obfuscate and but like you said
there's no they it's just anyone that
wants to become a hacker and say i'm
anonymous
and you know when it first started there
was a small group who were doing it it's
like 500 and there was only a few of
them who were prominent and actually had
the skills and then once they got
popular press all of a sudden you
started getting all of these videos
popping up on youtube where it was like
anonymous declares
and the initial like concept was if you
have a thousand anonymous individuals
and people propose things randomly
whatever is popular rises to the top
so a lot of the actions that were being
taken by anonymous was like someone said
you know operation this let's do it and
people would be like that's stupid and
then someone will be like opera
operation abc and they'd be like all
right and they'll start doing it and
then it gains popular traction
so you still have attempts at you know
making these videos but for the most
part the movement or whatever of like
this kind of meritocratic hacktivist
operation just doesn't exist anymore
that's why i think now i think it's
government actors yeah yeah because i
think if you get
i mean not to say that i know a lot of
hackers but
the people i do let's say that possess a
skill set
i don't know that you could get five of
them to agree on anything probably not
yeah
um the one thing i will say is that the
hacker community has gone full cult for
the most part uh i know so i used to
hang out
i'd go to def con black cat hang out
hacker spaces and they were free speech
anti-establishment anti-government
and then the last time i went to defcon
which is the biggest hacker convention
it's uh for like like
civilian hacker convention because they
have black cat which is the corporate
one there was a guy i think he was from
the nsa or something and he was giving a
presentation and he mentioned how they
try and stop russia and everyone started
clapping and cheering and he was like
and then he stops and he goes wow an
applause from def con for for a spook
i'm really surprised things are changing
and i started laughing it was because
the media had been running the narrative
of russia
and i mentioned um there was like this
semi-open event there
and i'd mentioned that rt had offered to
pay me money for some of my footage out
of sweden which i said no to i said no
because i was like why do you my footage
is on youtube for free you can fair use
it there's literally no reason to give
me money for this it sounds weird yeah
and i got people clapping for me i was
like so when i was reporting out of
sweden i got hit up by rt they asked
they asked if they could pay me i said
no they doubled the amount they pay me i
said no then all of a sudden people i
knew were like hey i'm getting hit by
guys from rt they're trying to pay you
for this and i was like no and people
were like oh so brave so honorable and
i'm like
well i don't i've it's weird it was a
weird shift that happened where like the
corporate press said putin bad and
everyone just went you got it we're
going to march so weird do you think
that was just because of putin or do you
think that had something to do with i
mean not only that i mean let's face it
like putin's not a good guy i get that
yeah but but the attention on him do you
think it was just putin do you think
that was a combination of putin and
trump oh it's putin and fear of the cold
war there's so much residual fear of the
soviet union that put that fear onto
russia it's not the same country at all
it's not completely different it's not
communist it's it's a federation of
states
so it's it's like an easy target but
it's so it's like it's it's tickling
their amygdala i brought that up before
it's like it's it's enticing their
lizard brain to be become afraid of some
ancient idea ancient ancient evil like
does he still have the ring or is the
ring
the glacier is melting he's going to be
free
i think it's a cult
well we have this story from timcats.com
nearly 70 percent of liberals say it's
more important to protect ukraine's
border than our own what i don't know if
it's seventy percent i gotta get it
i thought it was 57. you have a link to
the poll on this one because it might be
okay but i i think that okay that
doesn't surprise me and i and i think um
yeah it's 57. reason doesn't surprise me
because there's there's a lot of people
that i know again i always make a
distinction between liberal and the left
but there's a lot of people on the left
and i know that
any other country in the world is better
than our own like we are we are uniquely
evil in some capacity for which we must
pay you know you know
i don't know
we just need to be sorry all the time
and so the idea that you would ask them
should we protect our border ukraines of
course it would be ukraine's because the
only way we protect our borders if you
know we're all a bunch of racists this
defies jesus's logic did you did you
splank out of your own eye first did you
see that they're calling on cbp to leave
the southern border to go to poland to
process ukrainian refugees
it's it's remarkable i'm gonna check
that out as things that things that
don't surprise me anymore yeah
things that don't surprise me anymore
wow
so okay back to the story for a second
you said it's 57 58 percent 57 of
democrats so not the title was wrong but
we're going to copyright that i think
the title is okay so somewhere between
57 and 70 but you think it's more close
to 57
49 of them
well you got to log into uh tourism if
you want to get the hard numbers i the
idea that we should send our national
guard overseas to fight is completely
insane that's completely insane
our custom and border protection agents
like border patrols like our border
patrol their job is to run the border
and they're like go to poland oh yeah
is it do you think it's because they
fired so many people for not being
vaccinated no that actually sounds like
they would allocate resources like
you're a border patrol and there's a
border issue in that crane okay that's
where you should be
right and and by the way does ukraine
have a coast because we have a coast
guard we do yeah that's right
yeah they got a they got a coast and off
the black sea they have a government so
they could use our army yeah
you know governments need armies they
could have arms ships wow man that's why
i was saying the other day i'm like i'm
ready to put my feet up and crack open a
coconut no never never never give up
never surrender always chance always
change so much give up but kind of like
just glide you know well that's good
like we're we've fallen off the cliff
just spread your wings and enjoy i do
think we need to make uh entertainment
for a while and veer away from the
negativity and of war and conflict and
so i don't think those two interestingly
enough i don't think those two things
are mutually exclusive not an either or
a proposition in fact i'm i'm willing to
say and again this is not one of those
this is not one of those you know george
bush we just got attacked so go shopping
right like i'm not saying that
um i i do i do think there's a realm for
like you know sacrifice when the times
call for it
but
like i as i look at like all the things
that are kind of under assault the way
things are acting
there there is a huge realm right now
one of the reasons why we are in the
situation we are right now
is because we didn't fight for the
cultural space
um
we you know we might fight for the
political space we didn't fight for the
cultural space which is why it is
dominated by by a certain perspective or
viewpoint and i i tell parents this all
the time when they're like well how are
we going to fix our schools or how are
we going to like well if you think
you're going to fix your schools with
one election cycle you're out of your
mind yeah because your child your child
is now going to a school which in many
cases is pushing a particular world view
or particular you know propaganda that
might not coincide with your own beliefs
about your country or faith or whatever
i said then they come home and they they
watch the t they watch netflix right and
chances are whatever they're watching
there is going to be pushing a
particular worldview then they turn on a
song which is pushing a worldview then
they look at the media which is personal
worldview and then they go to their
college professor which is personal
worldview and then what do you get 30
minutes around the dinner table
you think this is sufficient and so any
any sort of activity i see which is
pushing into that cultural space which
is so critical because everything
political is downstream from culture
is absolutely necessary and one of the
most important like fronts that we're in
right now but there's two good things to
say here some some optimism one is
you've got the daily wire
ramping up production of cultural uh
content they're buying movies
they're they're absolutely they
absolutely see your point and they're
working towards it but then i would say
that um when you say we haven't you know
gotten gotten involved in the culture or
forgot exactly how you said it well ian
and i uh did not come into this as
conservatives yeah so there's a lot of
people who
were working in some kind of
entertainment some kind of media or
cultural space and now find themselves
in agreement on many core issues of
freedom in the united states and our
constitution with conservatives and
that's giving a big cultural boon yes
it's so you know we we talked with the
guy from the daily wire about you know
how we can expand our cultural uh
content we have a vlog we do silly jokes
and have fun and we do flips and into
bean bags and stuff but we're talking
about you know things we can do we
launched a show called tales from the
inverted world yeah which is and we have
a book
available at
invertedworldbook.com and it's mysteries
mysteries ufos ghost stories because um
you know we've always been involved in
that yeah we actually got a mix of a
song that uh that we've been putting
together
so we so we're putting out music so
we're gonna yeah it's fantastic stuff
goosebumps so like i grew up playing
music i grew up making skate videos i
grew up making you know videos with my
friends and now
what the what the left is kind of
screwed up is that
they're they're constantly pushing
people
they're making authoritarian demands of
people to give in to their politics and
their views or else and a lot of people
are saying or else and they're walking
away yeah yeah so now there's an
opportunity here for conservatives to
get back in the game yeah and push back
on the left and i think in the long run
the left will lose the
the culture i was in hollywood acting in
2006
kind of and i was like i'm going to
change the world i'm going to become a
famous actor and then be able to give
the speech at the oscars that changes
everyone yeah that was my idea but it
was so dirty that industry i felt so
sexualized and they were like just so
sexy sex sex i'm like it's gotta be
right out of here man that'll be tough
felt their fingers coming at me and i
just ran but but i bailed on culture for
like a decade i started building minds
the social network you know that's
that's why people get involved in
politics is because we're not pretty
enough for hollywood and we're too
stupid for the private sector so yes
case in point but it's got to be done
it's got to be done it's one of them i
didn't like that top-down uh pressure in
hollywood of like the the oligarchs of
hollywood that were these like weird
sexual deviants seemed like they were
kind of creating the the feel or the
energy of the system it was gross yeah
beautiful city though until recently i
guess because the homeless
incursion is terrifying but beautiful um
weather that's for sure because of the
valley
the mountains and it's like you got
snow-capped peaks to the north an hour
you got the desert to the east in an
hour you got the ocean to the west in an
hour you got the the hills just 20
minutes north of you the beautiful
valley that it's incredible city oh yeah
they called it the city of the angels
for a reason yeah actually it's it says
los angeles has a really weird long name
yeah it's it's like super long it's like
the river of the women who uh
some like really long are you saying
yeah i'm looking enough now yeah we look
at california man and uh
they say california is our future the
california is five years ahead of the
rest of the country no so here's what i
think i think california is going to be
a wonderful place to live in about 20
years and then texas is going to be the
problem yeah i agree
that's why people people were telling us
like you should go to austin i was like
no way oh so i call i call it the and i
i did this once and i think it was like
occupy democrats or blue virginia or
someone got like fears like i can't
believe he called us locust because well
it's it's the locust theory the locusts
have no idea that they're the ones
eating all the crops they're just
wondering why all the prosperity's gone
and then they go somewhere else to find
more crops i'm like okay so no i'm not
comparing you to people to locust i'm
saying that it's this idea that someone
will come in see all this prosperity
you know use it then destroy it and then
when they move they don't realize that
okay you're taking the policies that
created the destruction with you
maybe don't do that this time yeah yeah
i'm not calling people locusts i'm
calling them a virus
[Music]
i think this is the mindset of the world
economic forum is that people are
destroying with recklessly without
reproducing the environment so they were
like okay that's a big problem yeah they
look they look at people like a fire
like animals yeah just consuming carbon
and expanding the growth and just
burning things down
it's fascinating they never want to take
a look at the fact i can't remember who
it was that had the bet but it was with
that um oh gosh it was with
one of these one of these guys that was
predicting in the 70s that we would be
engaged in a series of world famines and
like all of our natural resources would
be paul uh
earl wreck
good guess though
if you're talking about a guy that makes
crappy predictions paul krugman would
have been a really really good pick but
paul rowan and so this other economist
came in and i think he told him he's
like pick five natural resources and
i'll bet that in 20 years they're all
cheaper than they are today yep yeah and
and erwich engaged in the bed and lost
yes because it's this idea that no human
beings have this amazing capacity to
adapt
if they're not being controlled by oh i
don't know an authoritarian central
government that's trying to control
their lives or treating them like
they're a virus but how about we make
that bet now
do you think things will be getting
cheaper and i would i would say from
this point forward singapore
yeah yeah i think i think we're we're
we're in for a world of hurt
if we boot russia from swift
then everything's going to get more
expensive i got a story here i think
that russia is leaving swift i don't
think that they're going to wait to get
booted i got a story from russia
briefing.com russia and china to develop
swift avoiding international financial
systems what's that of course i just
don't know about the source but but
russia and china have been trying to get
off the dollar for a long time
so they they've i think putin's known
you can't imagine this guy has has risen
to the level he's risen to without
planning for something like this yeah
for sure
what would be interest we were
again i was talking about my team about
this like what do we think is the worst
case scenario
and what we were talking was like okay
he takes ukraine he uses that as kind of
like a trial balloon right takes ukraine
doesn't really suffer any major
consequences for it and then you start
to look at you know incursions into
places like uzbekistan kazakhstan
tajikistan where we're talking again the
belt and road initiative and now you
start to see this block this russian
chinese block where you have a massive
amount of natural resources you've
solved some of the the you know
population issues the russians have with
expansion and then you have just these
major spheres of influence
and then it becomes almost kind of like
a remake of the cold war on some level
now again i'm not saying this is going
to happen but i'm saying it's not
science fiction to look at this and be
like okay yeah i can look at a map and i
can look at what he's doing and i can
look at where resources are at and i can
see where spheres of influence would
potentially gain and then where do we go
from there
um
and and to your point back when it was
the west and the soviet union you had
people coming off of world war ii you
had generations that were familiar with
sacrifice familiar with fighting that
they had a strong sense of
patriotism they had a strong sense of
moral responsibility to themselves their
family their country etc and now you're
talking about a world where
i don't think anybody believes that we
have that same sense as widespread
throughout the population
uh given some of the things that we're
you know complaining about right now
and and some of the things that people
honestly believe are really key issues
um
and so it's
it's we're to look at where the
where the power dynamics gonna be from a
cultural standpoint at that point i
think moving forward if we look back at
home and we can see what's going on
culturally
i wouldn't i don't i don't i'm not so
convinced the u.s is going to be a major
player in international conflict the
same way they they are now or i i think
it's obvious that that influence is
waning but let's let's bring it back
home and talk about the you know right
back to the cultural issues so uh you
had
you know we were talking about schools
and school choice early on so i really i
really want to talk to you about this
and get your thoughts on what's going on
with with younkin you're in virginia
obviously
education played a huge role in a
republican victory in virginia so i'm
wondering if you can just you know
bring us up to speed on what's been
going on sure how you got involved and
where do you think where do you think
people are in this critical race theory
stuff so this is what's interesting
right so i think for the
first time i can remember in my lifetime
republicans won an election in what has
been increasingly a blue state
on the issue of education yes right
usually what do republicans went on jobs
we went on you know tax taxes right we
want regulations we don't went on
education right that's always been like
a democrat issue they always come off as
the ones that are more you know well
what happened was and i gotta i gotta
kind of set the scene here democrats
took control of
you know the the house of delegates the
virginia senate and the governor for the
first time in like over 20 years in
virginia
and there was one democrat delegate
lopez who uh represents i think it's
arlington and he had told people at this
one campaign stop because if you give us
everything we will accomplish a
lifetime's worth of work in an afternoon
and
keep in mind for 20 years they had to
have this sort of power so they got to
run on a lot of like aspirational things
like oh we're gonna equality and social
justice and equity like okay what does
any of that mean but it sounds good and
we're mad at republicans right now so
they got into power and they did it i
mean he was not lying they did as far
and as fast as they possibly could
within a two-year period of time then
they tried bannon like they tried
banning guns oh oh brother
there was there was a debate between me
and delegate mark levine he the same
people that said nobody wants to take
your guns all we want is common sense
gun control and then
every like 52 out of 54 democrats voted
for a bill that would have made you a
criminal for owning a 15 round magazine
so a low capacity magazine a 15-round
magazine well that's that's what i've
got in fact every single in fact every
single magazine you would have owned
that would have been a class one
misdemeanor with up to a year in jail
and twenty five hundred dollars right so
it wasn't just we're gonna get rid of
air force they wanted to retroactively
make people criminals yes yes right that
and they voted for this this is not like
oh some crazy loon passed this and they
killed it in the subcommittee no they
voted for this
all right so that's where they're at and
then you saw the same thing they did
this whole like cultural competency
training right because who could be
against cultural competence competency
just like who could be against equity
who could be against tolerance and what
this what this did is it set up this
process whereby teachers in virginia in
order to get their license to renew
their license had to go through cultural
competency training well when you go on
to the road map to equity in virginia
education website that's where you found
out that oh wow there's even mex kindy
there's robin d'angelo there's southern
poverty law center like all pushing crt
now what happened was his parents were
starting to see this stuff arrive in
their classrooms their kids are coming
home and they're making comments about
it at the same time democrats had
removed like reporting requirements for
principles for certain like criminal
acts happening within a school
and so you have this perfect storm
especially in northern virginia loudoun
county was like the the hot spot for
this
where students are coming home and
talking about what's going on and and
the parents aren't liking it and then
you had a certain like you know equity
restrictions that were taking place
where now certain students that would
have qualified before are not making it
into certain schools or certain programs
then you have a case where now you have
a a
i don't even know it was a transgender
female who's it was a biological male
that was wearing a dress right there
this person wasn't trans yeah okay it
was just a guy it was a guy wearing a
dress yeah so that was that real quick
the news was reporting that it was a
transgender student but if you actually
read the details it was just a student
who wore a dress and was going in the
girl's bathroom it was a male student
not transgender so in in the girls bat
so here's the big part that kind of blew
up
was you had a father that went to a
school board meeting and they were mad
about a lot of things crt was part of it
they were mad about like some of the
bathroom issues and stuff like that
and the superintendent got asked
um or the president of the school board
went on asked about have there been any
assaults
in bathrooms because some of the parents
were mad about this idea like why is a
biological male going into a bathroom
and they said you know no
well this is the part where people hate
politics and this is the reason why
there was an ongoing investment there
was an ongoing investigation about that
so technically nobody had been convicted
of something right but
they sure as hell it had an incident it
was it was actually it was like forcible
sodomy
and then that student right that student
was quietly transferred to a different
school so they did call the police the
parents were notified but that student
was transferred to a different school
where that student then re-offended geez
wow right and and was actually has now
been convicted and is one of the few
minors that we have in virginia that has
actually been put
on the um registry yeah the sexual
registry sexual uh offenders registry
and the judge even said after reading
the psych review that it was terrifying
wow right so
you again you have this perfect storm of
all this taking place but what was
incredible was the democrats response to
it the democrats response to it was at
first was crt is nowhere in our
classroom and then people started to see
it and it was like
well no it isn't my client my kid just
said this you're a racist
[Laughter]
right well there's there's stuff going
on in my kid's school with respect to
the the bathroom that's not a statement
you're a bigot
and i think what happened and they
weren't saying this to like hardcore
conservative parents right we've all
heard about it
this is in fairfax right this is you
have now told you have now told an
indian immigrant family that they're
racist
because they're concerned about what's
going on in their kid's school
and and it was this and real quick these
these these school boards are like white
progressives tell oh minorities they're
the racists yes
um or the sexist or the bigot or
whatever it is and i think what happened
was is that you had a lot of you had a
lot of people
that they weren't engaged in politics
you know they probably voted for joe
biden because they thought you know they
hated trump's twitter account right but
they had a real issue that they thought
that they could bring up they bring this
up to their elected representatives
and what they found out was no no the
moment you ran a foul
of the democrat narrative the
progressive narrative you're a racist
you're a bigot you're a sexist not only
that the father of that uh the girl who
was attacked was like violently dragged
out wasn't he oh yeah no no he was he
was arrested at that school board
meeting and it was funny because that
was one of the events that the
department of the the school board
association right the national school
board association wrote a letter to
the department of justice and that's
where they were trying to use
counter-terrorism law in order to crack
down at these meetings at school board
meetings and it wasn't until a reporter
i think with the daily wire
actually bothered to go to the the man
right go to the father and say so why
did you do this and he goes because my
daughter was raped in a loud and school
bathroom and they lied about it and they
covered it up and they transferred the
kid
loudoun county is literally 20 seconds
from here yes okay okay figuratively
it's about one minute if you're going a
million miles an hour like next door
it it literally is next door time and
space are the same thing
it's like a half mile maybe yeah uh you
drive down the road you make uh one left
turn yep one left turn from here and
you're in uh loudoun county and so uh
it's big though it's big though yeah no
it's big county the wealthiest county in
america right but you you you go to um
what is it what is it uh is it leesburg
or what's the what's the yeah leesburg
you go down there and um i mean it's
it's democrat yeah it is it is dc
suburbanite democrat types i was i was
surprised to hear this story because i'm
like when i'm hearing parents rising up
i'm like these aren't republicans man
i mean there were there were i mean
there were publishers too but it wasn't
just
if it had been just republicans we
wouldn't have seen the election results
we did i just mean to say that like the
narrative of the only people who are
complaining are republicans this is this
was regular suburbanite families yeah
you know of of many different
backgrounds but it wasn't just
republicans complaining about something
the media was trying to claim the far
right was doing it and white
supremacists and then uh we went we went
to a skate park
there's a really great skate park down
there catoctin and we saw uh like a
block away was a bunch of parents
holding up signs protesting about this
and i'm like just regular looking people
yeah but you're in a blue area yeah so
that that was what was really surprising
to me about the whole the whole fiasco
so so what is it so young can actually
runs on school choice right he doesn't
just run on the typical thing the
politicians we're gonna increase teacher
pay right we're gonna more money for
education he said no we're gonna run on
school we're gonna actually give parents
more control over their child's
education
and he and he wins on it and this is
like and so we see a series of bills
that come through the virginia house of
delegates the the republican-controlled
house of delegates we got education
savings accounts we got regional charter
school bills we've got lab school bills
we've got you know i had a bill i had a
bill called the safer schools bill and
what it did is says we have this grant
for scholarship funds which means if a
company wants to donate money for
scholarships for students to be able to
go to school they can do it there they
get a tax credit for it whatever right
every state has one we got one too i
said okay i want to make another type of
student eligible for this
and the type of student that will be
eligible is a student that has been
assaulted you know beaten up bullied
you got to go through a process
principal's got to investigate they got
to sign off on it but if they sign off
on it we will make funds available
through this scholarship fund for the
child to go to another public school
right i mean i had some big school
choice bills this was a really minor one
i figured let's do some good for some
kids that are getting beat up at school
or like this young girl that got raped
in a bathroom right let's do some stuff
to help them
democrats killed that on a straight
party line vote wow i can't say i'm
surprised though oh well and that's and
that's what we found is that with every
single substantive school choice bill
that we did this year it would pass out
of the house of delegates and then it
would go and die in the senate do you
think that the senate needs to be like
reorganized so that every citizen gets a
vote
no how is that that's just not i'm just
so tired of putting all that power in
the hands of 400 people
talking about the state senate how many
people are in the state senate of
virginia 40. 40 people get to decide the
life or death of a of a of a democratic
bill well technically no people vote for
their yeah both of their representatives
i mean i mean look i i don't think the
problem is the senate the problem is the
senators right it's who we have and and
i'll just say real quick make sure
you're voting in your local elections
make sure you're voting in your
primaries yeah those senators
we have nine so it's 19 republicans 21
democrats right that's the virginia
senate but it doesn't matter because
when you get to their subcommittees like
in in the house let me let me just
explain this process real quick i know
it's kind of boring but it's important
for people to know
bill comes in
speaker assigns it to a committee right
goes to
70 like 50 to 70 of the bills that you
see die die in a subcommittee somewhere
it's not debated on the house floor dies
in a subcommittee and it makes sense
because there's a lot of stupid ideas
and we don't all need to look at them
but anyways so you get a bill from like
some anyone no no no you got to be a
legislator to submit a bill we submit a
bill gets drafted and then we look at
all the bills and we say okay this bill
is for education education committee and
this is the subcommittee will be like
this one's not good enough no no no
subcommittee sits down like so i'm a
subcommittee chairman for public safety
all the gun bills come to my
subcommittee so you have a certain
number of republicans certain amount of
democrats on the subcommittee and we
hear the bill first and if and if we
have a majority of that subcommittee
that likes the bill it goes up to the
next level right but
in the house we do proportional
representation so we've got 52
republicans 48 democrats so if you look
at our committees that's that's
reflected in the numbers that we have in
the committees the senate 19 republicans
21 democrats you'll go to a senate
committee they'll have like
nine democrats and three republicans
yeah the federal government's like that
so there's yeah so there's no way you
can get so even though you if you make a
good enough argument gerrymandering if
you make a good enough argument you
might be able to get something out of a
out of a republican-controlled house
committee because we only got a majority
of two on the senate side they will
stack those committees and even if you
could get enough votes on the floor of
the senate they will make sure it goes
to a committee where it will never see
the lie today do you think that they
intentionally give
have senators pick the committees so
that there isn't a democratic voice
because the the compounding effect of
democracy that like mob rule can take
over no it's it it's just part of this
is
part of this is whoever the controlling
party is in a particular legislative
body they want to be able to control the
outcome for what legislation makes it to
the floor
and what gets sent over to the other
body but the thing is is what what we
did in virgin on the house of delegates
side what we said is like look
there needs to be proportional
representation on these committees
because it's a more accurate reflection
of what the the people actually elected
but you can manipulate that committee
process pretty bad and again it's not
every committee but it's it's been
frustrating i think it should be i
talked with thomas massey about this yes
we got to do that in the federal
government as well it's ridiculous that
the democrats win by 51 percent and then
they pick all the committee chairs
because that one it doesn't and they
make sure the ones that matter the most
they have the majority on yeah they can
shuffle people into the the you know oh
the republicans can have a committee we
don't care about yeah yeah it's got to
change so did you guys change it in
virginia we change so we still select so
the majority party gets the the
committee chairs that i mean that just
that just happens it doesn't make sense
for it to not happen that way the the
difference is is that we don't stack our
committees like who picks who how they
get the speaker
most people understand how much power
the speaker of the house has the speaker
of the house has an enormous amount and
the speaker will say you have to pick
three republicans and two democrats for
this and so then they look and they
decide and in virginia yeah we have
again because we have proportional
representation it's like okay you're
going to have this many republicans this
many democrats
yeah do you see people change party
affiliation on paper so that they can
get into a committee when they're
actually still this doesn't work that
way
it doesn't work that way you gotta you
gotta run you gotta read you gotta run
for the party's nomination get elected
that you could theoretically try to
switch when you're there but that
doesn't happen
will you propose a bill to uh pass
constitutional carry in virginia i
carried the bill this year oh
restitutional carry and then the
democrats
so yeah we had so we had a we had a
house version we had a senate version um
they the senators killed the senate
version right away and so the ours
didn't go forward all right because
everyone says well we'll do that we'll
look at bills so we no i carried a i
carried a lot of gun legislation i
usually do but um
virginia's not so bad maryland is is a
nightmarish yeah the law's up here but
uh man constitutional care would be
something great because we live in the
tri-state and so i i live in west
virginia we work in maryland west
virginia is fantastic
oh yeah you can you can conceal carry
you can carry west virginia's past great
school choice legislation they've got i
mean no they've done a lot of good work
some of the pushback i've heard on
school choice
is that if everyone has the opportunity
to send their kid to whatever school
they want in the surrounding area that a
lot of people will go to the good school
first and all these other schools that
need students for money are going to go
out of business or get worse this is why
you should fund students and not an ins
and not a particular building
and and again we've gotten so used to
the way education has been monopolized
and run by the government that it's hard
to imagine another way to do it but but
think about again think about the way
you buy anything else
right you you don't have a government
store you go to in order to buy
something right like let's hear that
story about the stuff so the way the way
i've described this before is we all
agree education is important we also
agree eating is important so let's
imagine that the government at some
point said you know what eating is so
important that here's how we're going to
do this we're going to set up thousands
of government grocery stores all over
the country and then you're going to be
assigned a government grocery store
based off of your address now when you
show up to the grove government grocery
store you're not going to actually shop
for your groceries your groceries will
be decided for you based off of the
government board and the caloric intake
or the nutritional necessities of your
particular family now if you don't like
something in the grocery bag not a big
deal all you have to do is show up to a
bunch of board meetings or go and lobby
your state legislature in order to get
you know a different product into your
grocery bag or out of your grocery bag
oh by the way none of the employees
working at this government grocery store
will be rewarded based off of creativity
ingenuity or work ethic they will only
be rewarded based off of seniority
does anybody think
that is a grocery store you would want
like would you want that to be your
grocery store option no negative no i
haven't had a single person surprisingly
enough i've not had a single person yet
go oh my gosh that sounds like great but
i think you know
i don't know about ian but i'm in favor
of school choice well well here's
interested in learning more about it but
but here's the here's the point i go
back and i say okay
but what i just described is exactly
what we did with public education you
are assigned a government school based
off of your address when you show up to
the government school you don't have any
say over the curriculum over the class
or very very limited say over what you
can do if you have a problem with what's
being taught or with what's not being
taught great try to re-elect your school
board or maybe go to the state
legislature and try to get something
changed there and by the way none of
your teachers are rewarded based off of
how good a job they do they're just
rewarded off a seniority not to mention
the fact now again everyone can then see
in that example that okay maybe there is
a better way to run education
how would that look
and the thing i say was okay well
are you happy with the grocery store
options you have yeah are you happy with
the options that you have to buy a
smartphone are you happy with the
options you have to go and do other
educational opportunities yeah okay well
then maybe that's because
when you as the customer of the product
or service have the power
the rest of the world is trying to get
you to be their customer yeah okay the
government doesn't have that incentive i
don't need you to be my customer i don't
need you to like what i'm doing would
the schools be able to be like hey if
you come to our school it'll be easier
to graduate or will there be some sort
of government over here here's the thing
is that what a parent wants for their
kid i don't know i don't know what they
want i don't even know if they they want
education i think primarily they want
them to understand how to learn they
they want them to understand how to
learn and then really what they want is
they want them to be able to learn the
basic
you know social and economic skills
they're going to need to be an
independent adult right and
that's your that's your oversight
mechanism it's not to say you can't have
some you know government restrictions or
guard rails you can
but the oversight restriction is
no i as a customer want the best for my
child and now i have the ability to go
find what that looks like that's on the
that's on the demand side on the supply
side
now all of a sudden you have this huge
world where
schooling is no longer based off of a
government building you go to khan
academy yeah jordan peterson if you
could divvy up your 18 000 a year
stipend amongst the great creators and
educators of our time that are on the
internet yes that'd be so great did you
get to meet matt walsh when he came down
i did not that was great he rented an
apartment so because they tried yeah
yeah a basement they tried stopping yeah
i know i know the people he rented from
though
so matt walsh was going to speak they're
like oh we got to be a resident so he's
like all right so he rented it and he
rented a basement i guess that was great
brilliant right let's go to super chats
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends if you really
want to help out become a member at
timcast.com sign up get access to our
exclusive members only segments and your
membership will also keep our
journalists funded we'll now go to your
super chat so get your super super chats
in we'll read what you guys have to have
to say oh here's an interesting name
trinidad a shop at a pressure says nick
freitas big fan of yours from culpepper
virginia glad to see my rep on one of my
favorite shows thank you very much
absolutely and thanks for saying we're a
favorite show i appreciate it
all right
joseph
la liberte says nick has two great
speeches one about a green beret and the
other about gun control this dude is
awesome i love this guy he's my hero
i appreciate wow you know ben stewart
you you have a great audience i know
right
one day i want to get you and ben
stewart next to each other and break the
internet because i think you guys look
so similar that that will break i'll
break the internet i get i get told i
look like the guy off of uh outer banks
that's always trying to steal the gold
from the kid i don't know stealing the
gold yeah the bros durham says hey nick
why don't you come down to hampton roads
and rep for us
all right so
don't get me wrong hampton roads
wonderful place briefly live there but i
do i do enjoy the piedmont of virginia
but uh you've got some good people down
there in the hampton roads area am i a.c
cardoza and uh i i hung out down there
for a few months anderson yeah i thought
it was a lot of fun yeah
hampton roads man go hang out in norfolk
a little bit virginia's a big place yeah
it is very big
let's grab some super chats
david sanchez says fifth time trying to
super chat well i got you now buddy in
the future if biden does nothing
substantial to protect what does that
say to protect
the world what i don't know you think
there is anything the next con
congressional election congress election
can force him to address or aid taiwan
um
i don't know
i think there's like a typo in you know
you tried five times but there's like a
weird type of okay yeah that is strange
is there anything the next congress a
congressional election can force him to
address hmm
i don't know if so much it's about the
congressional election i think it's
public pressure and if they see the
polls clearly the cdc is now announcing
oh we're going to pull back on the masks
and everything yeah because they know
they're they're they're spiraling oh
yeah yeah i thought it was funny that it
wasn't the
it wasn't the medical science that
changed on max it was the political
science with respect to the polling that
that caused them to finally wake up to
the fact that maybe this is not a good
idea hey we're going to lose an election
huh yeah all right
gunn griffin says for nick in vietnam we
weren't prepared for insurgency warfare
with general westmoreland attempting a
conventional war after 60 years of
regular warfare are we prepared to
return to conventional that's a great
that is a great question because he's
absolutely right um
we
for the last 20 years we we've built the
military around the idea of
counterinsurgency and you know initially
a little bit was was uw but mainly
counter-insurgency now it's getting back
into the realm of actually trying to
fight a large conventional conflict and
we can see the potential for something
like that happening with russia i think
we can recognize the potential for
something like that happening with china
as well so i will say that i know it was
a concern that was being addressed but i
mean let's let's face it the united
states military has a track record for
fighting the strategy of the previous
war and so there's always going to be a
learning curve that takes place when you
have an
officer corps or an nco core that has
grown up in kind of one style of
fighting and then you move into a
different style
there's
it can be difficult the one thing i will
say is that
while the united states military has not
always been the best at
predicting the next sort of tactics that
would be necessary for the for the next
conflict
it does have a track record of adapting
usually very quickly in order to
overcome so
here's a good one from vashts he says
you and others keep saying trump would
have been better i need to remind you
hong kong fell to china under him so i'm
not so sure
yes that is a good point but i would add
that was the uk and china having wasn't
negotiation in the 90s i think it was
and so this was a long setup chain of
like timeline that we knew was going to
happen and it was all done through a
legal process with the uk and china and
there were protests
but it's not the same as you know russia
invading a sovereign nation yeah i mean
i think it's important at that point
hong kong was part of china's
jurisdiction there were certain there
were certain agreements with respect to
how their government would be run for
like another 50 years that that's a
little bit differently than a
you know full-on invasion of a sovereign
country
i mean but again it still was horrible
random username says when trump says he
will bomb the golden turrets he's
talking about bombing churches yes
i i i should have clarified that maybe i
assumed people understood he's talking
about the you know the the steeples
and the spires and stuff he's talking
about blowing up churches in a civilian
city and maybe vladimir putin was like
this guy's nose this guy's nuts
man
brook harrington says i have a co-worker
with family in russia i'm told they were
bombed by ukraine first two days ago any
validity to this
what i don't know if that's true um i
can tell you this
with rt going down you better believe in
the west they're going to try and
restrict information coming out of
russia yeah and you better believe
russia is going to try and manipulate
you into believing they're you know
being victimized i think yeah i think
both of those statements are absolutely
true the one thing the one thing i would
question is i don't know what it gets
ukraine
to be the initial aggressor oh for sure
yeah that's insane i do not know what
would yeah yeah all right marco says i
am from norway russia has always done
military practice outside nordic sea for
like 20 years never been problematic
even russia helped norway under world
war ii on the nordic side of norway
interesting i love the history of russia
in the united states is great because it
was like we were enemies but we worked
together to defeat a common enemy and
that's what we should be doing today
gosh what the heck
yeah well the story of uh east and west
germany is
i mean the story of the soviet union
brutal you ever you ever hear the story
of tetris the video game oh no
it's there's there's an urban legend
with the guy we've all dated ourselves
basically there was a um there was a
game in russia they were playing where
you would take the tetris shapes but
just place them
and then some dude made the block
falling version yeah and it's like how
do you in russia make a product that can
be commercialized internationally how
does it even work yeah and so i guess
like russia it was communist and they
were like it's communist so we get you
know but apparently everyone in the west
just ripped them off anyway and they're
like lawsuits crazy story um
there's a two-player tetris on the nes
that got they got sued into oblivion it
was made by some other company that was
always crazy to me like why would anyone
respect an international lawsuit during
a cold war yeah you know some guy's like
i made a video game it's like well he
won the lawsuit right it's like the
bureaucrats are still trying to make
money off of it yeah that's what war is
for those guys
let's grab some more super chats oh
people are saying my camera's blue yeah
i don't know why that happened sometimes
yeah well i am blue
says josh thanks josh
eiffel 77 i think is out of that song
yeah they wrote that they brought it
back for one of the iron mans right i
love that song yeah cj says when trump
took office isis was the top foreign
policy issue he set aside our
differences with russia to solve that
problem and the deep state hated it
meanwhile the minsk agreement stewed
yeah um because i think i think the us
was hoping that isis would destabilize
syria so that we could get a more
favorable regimen and then we could
build our pipeline through syria
but
trump getting rid of isis
while the right thing
well yeah i think the the the
bureaucrats the military industrial
complex were were upset
weird stuff would have went down with
isis and the syrian rebels i got to tell
you that yeah
uh clarify to his eiffel
that song blue number great song
c griff says it's time for the u.s to
leave the u.n it's nothing but global
bureaucracy and sanctions which never
really do anything to determine
to determine countries like russia and
china so here's where i disagree the u.n
does a lot like for instance they will
write strong notes of protest they do
yes um to israel and may i just add
before we continue i've heard they've
wagged their finger about the u.n
and shaken their fist quite fiercely
stomped at their foot perhaps guys guys
the u.n security council revolution con
uh resolution concerning condemning
sorry i can't read russia for the
invasion of ukraine has failed due to
the russian vote
yeah
no like i i honestly
again this is someone that i i'm all for
foreign engagement i'm all for i think
it should be primarily economic and
cultural you know as little as possible
um but i look at the united nations and
what is it doing at this point other
than
giving an air of legitimacy to brutal
dictatorships that don't have genuine
democracies or are regularly trampling
on people's civil liberties and like the
number one thing the u.n does is pass
resolutions condemning israel like i i
don't i'm sorry i don't see i have a
hard time seeing the point are you
familiar with the non-aligned movement
no isn't this amazing it's the it's the
other un it's global it's 120 countries
are in this non-aligned movement it's
the countries that aren't in the u.n
basically all of africa south america i
think mexico's in it uh iran
headquarters they're all on the u.n yeah
yeah oh no they're uh they're not blue
you check them out this is really the
non-aligned movement and you can get a
map of it interesting there's light blue
and dark blue so mexico's light blue i
gotta read this is this very very good
super chat here turk say no to war
longwell says dude biden hitting a speed
bag was a total 100
wow
good stuff
oh yeah for sure thanks turk i got you b
all right
thrawn says can't show you joe biden
hitting a speed bag but i've seen a few
picks of hunter hitting a speed ball oh
that's right
i'd be fine with a deep fake of hitting
speed back at this point yeah i just
want to see it happen a video really
fast you know like you see his muscles
twitching in his arms something from
rocky iii
yeah
kevin uh kevin d
sturm troopin gun says the vietnam story
you are referring to is operation
wandering soul there's plenty of uploads
of the actual declassified tapes the cia
made to blast on speakers supposedly
gave us servicemen a bit of a fright too
oh
i think we should just do that in our
woods right outside yeah that's a good
idea big speakers and just play like
waiting and then just act like you don't
know what your neighbor do
yeah did you hear that thing i'm sorry i
shouldn't have done it people like
apologizing to you for what they did and
stuff yeah that would be hilarious i
shouldn't have broken into tim's house
i'm sorry i'd be trying to trap you
don't drink the water oh my gosh
all right dragon lady says evening y'all
no cast castle today that makes me sad
need my bucko fix
yeah he was sick i just hugged him
earlier yeah oh nick wasn't feeling well
today yeah no he had uh he was sick the
other day so yeah go to youtube.com cast
castle if you want to see what it's like
inside the the cass castle operation how
we make all of the how does it how do
you make it the sausage made yeah the
sauce it will shock and devastate you
it's horrible and um that's why i showed
up today i was told there would be
sausage oh yeah it's true
i'm sorry there's leftover pizza from
papa john's oh there you go that's good
and a lot of chicken nuggets or whatever
chicken wads
chicken ones yeah wads of chicken we buy
they're just wads of chicken
all right let's grab some more other
grab some more zombie chip
oh people are mad at ian mitch marco
says i don't know what's more annoying
ian claiming to love the art of movies
despite not seeing a movie made in the
last 20 years or getting caught up on
words that have nothing to do with the
route word the the word
that the second one's more annoying the
one where i get caught up in words is
more annoying it's more annoying okay
all right now here's a good one
jay schartzer says tim bring lex
friedman on when he's back he went to
russia to talk sense to people oh good
don't know if that will work out but
he's a smart guy so who knows
i mean yeah i'd love to but lex is a
super busy guy yeah you know people who
already have shows you know you got to
work around their schedule and
especially someone like lex he's got a
big show but i will say sometimes it's
more important i think he would come on
and report the conversation and talk
about it that's now's the time was
always invited in of course yeah he hit
me up once about you know doing
something with his show and then never
happened he was too busy love him well
no i was oh yeah because he hit me up
and i was like bro i don't know if i can
do it but um
tim went with the power play there i'm
sorry i'm busy i can't i can't go on
your shoulder no i'm i'm lex is
fantastic i'd love to but uh i was busy
and then i got back to him and i was
like you know what i think i can do it
and he's like ah now i can't and i'm
like oh you know like hit me up
man it'll be a great conversation but uh
i'd love to have them that'd be
fantastic
all right
adrian says do you know anything about
the ukrainian u.s bio labs that russia
hit love the show keep up the good work
i don't think they did there was a meme
showing a map saying like here's where
all the bio labs are and here's where
russia attacked but they didn't line up
we talked about this last night yeah
yeah it they didn't line up i'm no fan
of snopes but snopes pointed that out
too like the maps aren't the same like
the attacks aren't in the same place
ukraine pennsylvania it's a difference
yeah so john boyce has alex friedman
announced today he's he's heading to
ukraine to speak to friends and then to
russia to speak to putin don't think
it's possible but if he does it's crazy
your thoughts i think it's a bad idea
for
for lex
i'd say it's a bad idea oh i don't think
so he's been planning it for a while
with putin they've been at least he
talked about a couple weeks ago
well before all this actually with
vladimir putin yeah that's that's good
then that's absolutely fantastic
absolutely i'm thinking about him going
into ukraine because
i would
uh
you you you gotta you gotta have a
certain understanding of urban conflict
i mean you know what are your thoughts
on war would you recommend i don't i
don't know alex's background but what i
recommend urban out of all the conflicts
would you recommend no no i mean like
would you
lex friedman's background i don't think
is in is in conflict i don't know if he
has that experience like i personally
wouldn't recommend somebody to go into a
conflict if they don't have any
experience no it's generally a bad idea
especi especially something like this
where it's very fast moving you're gonna
have a lot of you again
as the russian lines move forward and
you have like pockets of troops that are
in urban areas as they hand out like you
know weapons to their civilian
population to be able to fight back
you're gonna have a lot of people
running around and playing clothes and
whatnot just because it's the nature of
warfare so if you're running around and
playing clothes
sorry dude like i don't know what to
tell you yeah right maybe you want to be
wearing a t-shirt and shorts yeah or
just like a speedo and nothing else
because no they're not gonna if if they
see a guy who looks like a weirdo
okay so in that area of the world
running around in a speedo nothing else
in the winter it's pretty normal
is
if you're a regular person in plain
clothes wearing a jacket
they're going to kill you you need like
a hawaii because you could be somebody
who's armed you could be part of the
conflict and they don't know and and no
one's no one wants to take the chance if
they don't know you and you're not from
their neighborhood oh yeah don't expect
to get like don't expect to be able to
speak the language either i mean that's
a huge i was i was in my dan
during the uh the protests that started
in 2014 uh in 2013 and in 2014 and they
eventually got to the point where they
built these massive barricades around uh
you know independent square whatever
they call it and um i was walking around
with my british uh producers from vice
we walked out when we came to walk back
in we got surrounded by like 15
ukrainian guys who were yelling at us in
ukrainian yeah and the only thing i do
is say like american
speak english yeah sorry and then
someone came in and started speaking
ukrainian and backed him off and they
were like american journalists and they
were like please please please come in
come in yeah but the guy's with me i'm
like they're british they're not
american
it was cool and actually we actually got
to talk to a former soviet general that
was super cool but uh when you go into
an area you don't speak the language and
they're all yelling at you
let me tell you man i was in uh um
turkey and we went to this neighborhood
they called like the last anarchist
neighborhood of istanbul
we tried there was a there was a street
where the anarchists were throwing
molotovs at cops and the cops were you
know holding the line and firing less
lethals so we went around
and went uh on a side street to try and
go in and we've got it's me and a guy
with a camera and another producer when
all of a sudden a whole bunch of turkish
dudes run up to us holding molotovs
screaming at us in turkish and one guy
holds a malta cocktail right up to the
side of my face
and my response i put my hands up i said
nothing and i just nodded and i slowly
turned and started to walk away
the guys i were with were like kind of
more excited yeah and i was just like
let me as we walked i was like guys guys
don't try and speak english in an
excited way to somebody who doesn't
speak english or is not speaking english
to you because the only thing they hear
is you going bad
back at them and they might think you're
aggressive so just you know put your
hands up nod and then just walk in the
direction they point yeah
i would just say man uh vice sent me on
some uh
vice had sent me out a couple times into
conflict with
producers who had no conflict experience
i just want to say it isn't it is
exciting
maybe the most stressful thing i've ever
experienced
is
knowing that i'm responsible for the
life of someone yeah because that
doesn't know what they're doing and
that's putting me in danger yeah
man
but i but vice is also you know to to to
to their credit
sent me out with people with way more
experience than i have and one of my one
of the most heartwarming moments was
when i was in ferguson and the first
gunshots went out and i'm already on the
ground and i look to my right my
producer's already on the ground as well
yeah and this is a guy who who had who
had been trained in firearms would you
know been to war because advice has some
good people they really do and i was
just like yeah i looked to my left
there's a guy from abc news standing up
looking around and he goes those
fireworks
and i'm just like oh man i felt bad
you're the guy you ain't gonna make it
but you know what i say to them
do you see anyone holding fireworks
do you see anyone holding guns
make an assumption
that's what we call deductive reasoning
it's crazy though like i've been on the
ground with people where the gunshots
ring out and they stand there like it's
just fireworks yeah
where do you think you are you know
what's you know what's
kind of an aside of that
it's because a lot of people again one
of the benefits of especially going up
in the united states is most people not
everyone most people have grown up in an
environment
where they really haven't had to
experience any sort of conflict or
deprivation or gunfire or so it's this
idea of like well that can't be
that like no no it actually can be
that's the craziest thing too as much as
the america is this gun country
people urban liberals have not heard a
gun go off they've heard movies where
it's like bang bang
or silenced
and then you hear a 22
and you know someone who's never heard a
gun would be like is that a firecracker
going off yeah and it's like no that
will kill you yeah yeah man who was it
who said you can conquer a nation was
abandoned you can conquer a nation with
1022 you know rifle like ruger 10 22's
interesting was it bannon maybe it
wasn't
we were talking to someone he's like
a thousand ruger 10 22s can take over a
small country
i'm like yes it's a weapon yeah
all right let's grab some more super
chats
v rise says the ghost of kiev has been
proven to be fake yet many left leftist
communities online acknowledge and
blatantly say they don't care that it's
fake they're still going to believe it
thoughts i have not seen any evidence
saying it's fake i'm not saying i've
seen any evidence say it's real to be
completely honest they're like this is
the ghost of kiev and i'm like that's
just a picture of a fighter jet it's one
picture yeah like how is it evidence of
any of this being true yeah
so sounds like manipulation as far as i
can tell it's not been proven or
disproven to me seeing about like um
what's his name from uh world war ii the
british guy i don't know why i'm
blanking on that
yeah that does not narrow the british
prime minister winston churchill yeah
churchill was like it was all about uh
more like mentality propaganda and
keeping people sane like giving them
giving them motivation he would like he
had no idea if they're gonna win or lose
but he would tell them they were going
to win yeah yeah
every night here's a good one from
damian simmons
in revelations the dragon gives power to
the beast the tale of the dragon will
rain down on three-fourths of the world
could china be the dragon and the beast
be russia maybe
interesting the dragon is humble i'll
tell you that i don't know what are they
called china russia the dragon bear yeah
the dragon bear
the bear
brick muppet says at least one letter of
mark was issued in the civil war they
are now banned by international treaty
paris declaration u.s never signed that
treaty okay
i was thinking of this earlier if the
hackers are the modern day i didn't
realize the civil war but that that's a
good uh yeah i thought it was madison
was the last one
the hackers are the modern-day pirates
being uh hired with letters of mark then
what about the people that are
controlling the algorithms at the top of
the companies that are being paid to
change the algorithms are they also
pirates are they being hired like ccp is
controlling tick tock and in china from
this is what i've learned in the last
week or so the algorithm is showing like
science technology it's just media
they're they're showing media to the
people
the the analogy here is just that's the
media in the united states the media was
completely on board with the war effort
and the government would go to them be
like don't report these things they'd be
like you got to choose so should we
consider them pirates like for hire no
if they're being doing what they're told
you're talking about aggressive action
toward like i mean
there's a long time relationship between
governments and media where they'll
essentially say you know restrict
certain information or they'll classify
a certain way so they can't report it or
they'll just voluntarily self-censor but
the letters are marked that's more it's
like i'm going to take this hacker and i
want this organization tracked and the
way you're going to do it is and again
i want you to hack all their bank
accounts and if you hack their bank
accounts you can keep some or whatever
or not even that be like here the
targets we want hit and we won't come
after you for hitting them yeah what
about like we want you to show this
algorithm here in this algorithm here
but you're talking about massive
corporations that work with government
that's not the same thing yeah so
think of a mark as almost like a bounty
yes that's a good way to say it yeah
okay
so
if the us government has a bunch of
corporations that produce weapons for
that's just the the crown's bowyer or
whatever probably the most famous like
privateer in history sir francis drake
yeah i'm concerned that a corporation
won't become uh uh go after one of the
bounties i wonder if that'll start
happening that governments will pay
corporations to take mark they don't
they don't need to you have like you
have a group of three dudes hanging out
in an apartment in moscow and the
government is just like oh won't someone
rid me of this priest wink wink and they
go you got it boss and then they do it
and then russia says oh those pesky
hackers why would they do this yeah
can't get mad at us we'll arrest them if
we find out who did it yeah and then
they don't of course they won't who done
it yup they want to be able to disavow
and say we have nothing to do with it
you can't don't look at it
well there's overt and covert letters of
mark
oh interesting yeah you you can you can
be overt about it like yep i put a
bounty which is like what was that
military company and that we had hired
hired guns in the middle east for a long
time yeah black water change they
changed their name well that that wasn't
even a letter or mark now you're just
being now you're just hiring a company
to provide a certain degree of certain
set of services that they're permitted
to do and most of it was like security
services for like bases or dignitaries
or things like that so like that would
be more mercenary just mercenary work
it it's it's interesting because
mercenary has like an actual definition
and then it also has kind of like a
colloquial understanding or like a
popular understanding of it um so there
was like a lot of what we think of when
we think of mercenaries is like
literally like the swiss guards or
something like that where you have
you have an element of
soldiers or troops that will essentially
fight for the highest bidder or whatnot
um then you have people that are paid to
provide you know military services
but it's it's not as if they're just
going to the higher but it's not like
you just go to whoever it's not like one
day we're working for the us government
the next day uh the cartels who knows
right um so
i think there's some distinction between
the two if that makes sense
all right chris scanipieco says
supposedly the former ukraine president
petro poroshenko confirmed the ghost of
kiev israel but he has a pretty good
reason to push the lie if it is a lie
it's propaganda even what's the story of
the ghost of kiev uh uh it's an ace
fighter pilot took out six russian uh
fighter jets in dog fights over kiev the
videos show there's there's dog fights
happening over kiev and um i've just not
seen any evidence that this is a single
pilot who took out six uh
fighter jets but a cool story oh yeah
you know um but it's a little bit like i
have confirmed the story that i am
awesome yeah
right right it's like the red baron but
he actually had like
locked down a hundred kills or something
they they need these stories yeah but
you know what you know what um
it just goes to show uh that the hero's
journey the story of strength and
masculinity resonates with people yeah
they're they're making modern day heroes
i'm all for it man i mean the ghost of
kev is a cool story if this is someone
defending their home it's not an
invasion it's defensive and and it's
it's the underdog fighting back and
taking out the aggressive force i'm like
it's a cool story yeah and if at the end
of the day it's going to inspire some
kids to be better people to defend their
families their friends their homes i dig
it you know what i don't like about
aggression and defense is that you can
have a country that is meddling other
places with like technology and not
sending a troop and then
you're basically the aggressor at that
point even though you haven't moved a
troop and so if you get attacked you
can't claim that you're the you're
defending yourself if you were out there
screwing with people and now they're
retaliating i don't think ukraine was
invading russia i don't know well the
u.s has been meddling and i think it's
like a proxy yeah but
as much as i think joe biden's crooked
with you know the deals he's worked in
the illegal quid pro quo and all that
stuff
trying to buy favors and influence with
cash vladimir putin had every
opportunity to do the exact same he
could have gone to uh to uh the
president of ukraine to i think was
support was it poroshenko he could have
gone to any one of these people and said
the u.s has offered you a billion
dollars in loans i'll give you a billion
dollars in loans as well the problem was
my understanding you know having been on
the ground in ukraine and talked to some
of the people and i still am regular in
community regular communication with a
friend of mine who's there is that they
don't like russia
they they the hall of demore these
people are like the soviet union
staged a genocide and it was it was
primarily russia staging a genocide over
the ukrainian people
you're exactly you're not you're it's
going to be hard-pressed to get popular
support across the board and so what was
happening was the us was playing their
influence games russia was playing their
influence games but a lot of people in
the country were still like we'd rather
be in the eu not to mention for a lot of
people in ukraine they were hoping that
getting into the eu meant they could
migrate out of the country and go get
jobs in higher paying countries
so when you look at what happened with
the eu people from poland where the gdp
was lower moved to the uk where the gdp
was higher and we're making more money
now people in ukraine were hoping for
the same thing that getting in the eu
would raise raise up you know all of
their wages and bring in more money and
russia wanted them to join the trade
federation he didn't have the influence
so what does he do like a whiny baby he
invades
is he like going to be out of office
soon what happened because he was prime
minister what was this you know what i
don't know about that something
something tells me their their uh
government structure doesn't work quite
the same as theirs yeah he just keeps
bouncing back and forth yeah
i've been kind of defending like hey
russia is a federation of states but
like dude if the dude seized control of
the government it's a dictatorship now
he's supposedly the richest guy on the
planet yeah
well my friends if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and go to timcast.com and become a
member to help support our work your
membership keeps the show sustained
keeps all of our journalists employed
and you'll get access to our exclusive
members only segments from this show you
can follow us at timecast irl basically
everywhere you can follow me at tim cast
nick you want to shout anything out no
again
lovely meeting all of you and thank you
very much for having me
yeah thanks for coming we've got we've
got a couple programs that we've been
working on one is making the argument
with nick freitas it's actually our one
of the things that we do on there is we
we actually try to you know equip people
to be able to make better arguments for
free markets for individual liberty one
of the things we do is kind of unique on
that we actually highlight bad
conservative arguments
because that's one thing that drives me
nuts is watching my own side make really
bad arguments and then we've got another
program we do call the y minutes where
we take you know actually one of the
issues that we were talking about
recently on there is we talk about the
environmental policy and stuff like that
and it's always this idea that if only
the government intervened more we'd have
better environmental policy so we like
to talk about things like the aral sea
and how wow centralized government power
was actually not better for the
environment along with all the other
things it's not good for but if you're
interested in individual liberty free
markets all that good stuff making the
argument nick freitas the yminutes
also you are nick for va on twitter on
twitter yeah yeah we have fun on twitter
and and the tick tock too oh wow
oh so i'm i've i've been we went from
like all my i went from 7 000 followers
to 200 000 followers in six months whoa
and then all of a sudden bam nothing
goes to the 4u page anymore but it is
still kind of funny because i like to be
able to tell my teenage daughters hey
how do you feel about the fact that you
know your your 42 year old father has a
bigger tick tock
lift they banned us i think it was
because of alex jones
we had alex on i don't care you know
whatever yeah i'm fine with it well hey
i'm ian crossland check me out in
crossland.net i'll see you guys next
week and thank you guys for tuning in
this evening i really enjoyed our talk
with nick freitas i forgot to shout out
the sign behind me that looks a little
crooked it's actually not uh they made
this amazing sign for me i need to shout
out the company that made it ian also
has one and then we have the tim cast
one mine has my cat in the at sign
that's dip you can find more of him on
my instagram way too much of him on my
instagram anyway i am sour patch lids on
twitter and mines.com we will see all of
you over at youtube.com cast castle
which will be up tomorrow and then we'll
be back monday thanks for hanging out
we'll see you all then bye guys
you